GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME.
TO THE.
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE.
FOR APRIL ELEVENTH I HAD TO
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT APRIL IS ALMOST
HALFWAY DONE SO WELCOME TO THE
FIRST PART OF OUR OUR HEARING
TODAY WHICH IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. OF THE SUBJECT IS THE
STATE OF AGRICULTURE IN THE
STATE AND WE'LL START WITH THE
REMARKS BY SECRETARY KAREN ROSS
WELCOME.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
JUST FOR YOU.
WE ALL FIVE.
IF YOU WANT.
WANTED TO MAKE.
TO MAKE WORKING I HEAR ME NOW
OKAY.
OKAY WE'RE READY TO GET OUR ACT.
THERE ARE FEW THINGS
SPECIFICALLY THAT YOUR STAFF
ASKED ME TO TOUCH ON.
BUT I'M ALWAYS HAPPY TO DO
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
FOR ME IS SUCH. A TREASURE FOR
THE STATE FOR THIS NATION THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO START WITH THE
NUMBERS AND THE NUMBERS ARE
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE FOR AS LONG AS
USDA HAS BEEN KEEPING RECORDS OF
WHAT THE FARM GATE VALUE IS OF
AGRICULTURE. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
THE NUMBER ONE STATE FOR OVER
SIXTY PLUS YEARS.
WE DO THAT WERE A LARGE STATE
BUT WE ALSO DO THAT IS THE STATE
THAT ALSO HAS FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS WHO ARE HIGHLY URBAN
MY STATES THAT HAVE THIS KIND OF
PRODUCTIVITY IS PRETTY
REMARKABLE.
THE MOST RECENT NUMBERS ON THE
VALUE OF AGRICULTURE HAS JUST A
LITTLE BIT OVER FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AT THE FARM
GATE.
THAT'S WITHOUT ANY VALUE ADDED
AND THAT THAT.
INCLUDES OVER FOUR HUNDRED
DIFFERENT COMMODITIES THAT WE
GROW HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND OF
COURSE THE TRADEMARK OF
CALIFORNIA ARE OUR SPECIALTY
CROPS
SPECIALTY CROPS ARE THOSE FRUITS
VEGETABLES TREE KNOTS OLIVE OILS
WINES CRAFT FAIRS. UP ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WE CAN GROW HERE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA.
HAS A MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE.
THAT MAKES A SPEAR UNIQUE THERE
ARE ONLY FIVE OTHER LOCATIONS IN
THE WORLD THAT ARE A BLAST
WITH THE MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE
THAT GIVES US THAT ABILITY.
TO PLAY. AND HARVEST A CROP
ALMOST EVERYDAY OF THE YEAR
SOMEPLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT IT IS
THAT WE PRODUCE ITS OVER HALF OF
THEM OF THAT NATION'S FRUITS
VEGETABLES AND TREE NUTS.
WERE THE WORLD'S FOURTH LARGEST
WINE PRODUCER WE ARE THAT
COUNTRY'S NUMBER ONE MILK
PRODUCER.
WE HAVE OVER TWENTY CROPS THAT
WE PUT WE ARE THE PRODUCER OF
OVER NINETY PERCENT. AND THAT'S
A LOT OF THE SPECIAL THINGS LIKE
ARTICHOKES AND FIGS AND OLIVES
THEM WINE GRAPES.
WE ALSO IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO BE THE SOURCE OF HEALTHY
NUTRITIOUS FOOD FOR OUR CITIZENS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE SHIP THAT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. BUT WE ALSO
NOW SHIPPED OVER A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN DIFFERENT MARKETS ON
A GLOBAL BASIS.
SO WE ARE A POWERHOUSE WE ARE
THE NUMBER ONE AGRICULTURAL X.
EXPORTER.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU'RE STAFF
WANTED ME TO TALK ABOUT IN
ADDITION TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
SPECIALTY CROPS.
THE FACT IS WE CAN THROW THOSE
THINGS HERE. THAT COULD NOT BE
EASILY GROWN AND OTHER STATES OR
EVEN IN OTHER COUNTRIES AND I
THINK THAT'S A FACT THAT BECAME
VERY EVIDENT DURING OUR DROUGHT.
THERE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
STARTED LOOKING OUT FOR MY
DINNER PLATE LOOK LIKE IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE.
SO WE CANNOT BE EASILY
DUPLICATED BUT THERE ARE SOME
DRIVING FORCES FOR AGRICULTURE
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE CHANGING
THAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CALL OUT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
IS THAT OVER NINETY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE FARMS IN THE STATE OUR
FAMILY. FARM OPERATIONS.
AND EVEN OF THAT REMAINING FIVE
PERCENT. MANY OF THOSE ARE
FAMILY CORPORATIONS OR THEY'RE
HELD IN TRUST
OR BY A STATE SO YOU HAVE THE
MISCONCEPTION ABOUT CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE THAT THOSE SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND FARMS ARE ALL ONE
SIZE THEY'RE NOT.
IF THE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE THAT IS OUR
STRENGTH.
SO WE HAVE MANY NEW BEGINNING
FARMERS FOR DOING VERY SMALL A
CREATES ON THE EDGE OF BIG URBAN
CENTERS WERE VERY FOCUSED ON
DIRECT TO CONSUMER MARKETS. AND
THEN WE HAVE LARGE SCALE MULTI
GENERATION FAMILY FARMS. WHO
THEY ARE VERY FOCUSED ON BEING
AND IF THE MOST EFFICIENT
PRODUCER TO SHIP THEIR PRODUCTS
AROUND THE GLOBE? AND I THINK
THAT'S OUR STRENGTH BUT HOW DO
WE IMPROVE THE RESILIENCE OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE. WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHAT THE DRIVERS ARE FOR
TRANS TODAY THAT WILL MAKE BIG
IMPACTS AND CHANGE ON
AGRICULTURE GOING FORWARD.
THERE'S A COUPLE MAJOR THINGS
ONE IS WATER. YOU CANNOT HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH ANYONE IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE WITHOUT
ACKNOWLEDGING.
THE.
IMPACT OF WATER AND THAT
ABSOLUTE NEED FOR MORE CERTAINTY
IN OUR WATER SUPPLY. THAT
SOMETHING THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS DEALT WITH FOR THE SEVEN
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE AND
THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT THAT
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE. AS WE
LOOK AT THE DEMANDS ON
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AND A
WORLD THAT'S GROWING FROM SEVEN
BILLION PEOPLE TO NINE BILLION
PEOPLE. AND THE ABSOLUTE NEED
FOR FOOD SECURITY WILL REQUIRE
US TO MORE THAN DOUBLE
PRODUCTIVITY IN AMERICAN
AGRICULTURE AND OTHER KINDS OF
CROPS WE GROW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AT THE TIME THAT WE'RE DOING
THAT. IT'S GOING TO BE WITH THE
SAME OR SMALLER ENVIRONMENTAL
FOOTPRINT THERE WILL BE LESS
ARABLE LAND ON A GLOBAL BASIS
AND LESS AVAILABLE WATER TO GROW
THOSE CROPS.
SO WHAT WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY.
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF AMERICAN AGRICULTURE
AS WELL AS TO WHAT OTHER
COUNTRIES CAN LEARN FROM US TO
FEED THEIR PEOPLE. AND THAT'S
THAT'S AN AREA OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S DRIVING A LOT OF THE
CHANGE THE OTHER AREA THAT I
KNOW YOU'VE ALSO HEARD A LOT
ABOUT. IS JUST THE INCREASING
CHALLENGES OF HAVING A STABLE
WORKFORCE FOR CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE.
THAT'S ALSO DRIVING THE
INVESTMENT WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW YOU'LL
BE HEARING FROM CUENTA ABOUT
THAT. ON WHERE WHERE CAN WE
AUTOMATE MARK WHAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN AUTOMATED HOW DO WE PERFECT
THAT HOW DO WE MAKE THAT MORE
PRECISE WHICH WILL HELP US BE
MORE EFFICIENT. BUT ALSO ONE OF
THOSE TASKS THAT EVEN A DECADE
AGO WE MIGHT NOT HAVE EVEN
ENVISIONED COULD BE AUTOMATED IT
ANYWAY. AND THAT'S WHERE THE
REAL CHANGE IS COMING AND I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT IF THERE WERE
EVER GOING TO BE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR. RESEARCH AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGY
IT WOULD BE AROUND HOW DO WE
BRING AUTOMATION. TO THE FARM AS
THAT HAS COME INTO OUR PACKING
HOUSES AS A HUGE NEED AND THAT
WILL DRIVE. CHANGE ON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE TODAY AND IT WILL
FOR THE NEXT FEW DECADES TO
COME.
I WOULD ALSO SAY WHEN WE LOOK AT
THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE THERE ARE NOT AS
MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE WILLING TO
DO THOSE KINDS OF JOBS THAT
REQUIRE MANUAL LABOR. BUT THAT
DOES NOT ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR
MANUAL LABOR A LOT OF OUR
SPECIALTY CROPS ARE HIGHLY
PERISHABLE A LOT OF CARE IS
REQUIRED FOR THAT. SO THERE'S
SEVERAL THINGS WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT AT OTHER WAYS OF MAKING SURE
WE HAVE A STABLE WORKFORCE ONE
IS HOW CAN WE HELP BRING
ADDITIONAL CERTIFICATION SO
PEOPLE HAVE CAREER LADDERS.
WHETHER IT'S AROUND FOOD SAFETY
IRRIGATION SPECIALIZATION PASSED
US PESTICIDE APPLICATIONS AN
ALTERNATIVE PASS MANAGEMENT
WAYS.
BUT THE IMPORTANCE OF VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION AND CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION WEATHER IS FOR MANUAL
LABOR JOBS OR ALL THOSE JOBS
THAT ARE BEING CREATED BECAUSE
OF TECHNOLOGY AND AUTOMATION.
THAT WE DO NEED PEOPLE TO BE THE
PROGRAMMERS WE DO NEED PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
REPAIR IT THOSE KINDS OF PIECES
OF EQUIPMENT. AND MAKE THE
ADAPTATIONS IN THE FIELD AND IN
OUR PACKING HOUSES.
WE ALSO SEE THAT MOST PARTS OF
ANY SIZE HAVE TO HAVE SOME
PEOPLE WHO ARE SPECIALISTS
AROUND IRRIGATION PEST
MANAGEMENT.
AND INCREASINGLY BEING INVOLVED
WITH OUR ABILITY TO ADAPT TO
CLIMATE.
AS I WANTED TO CLOSE MY COMMENTS
TODAY BY TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
ENTRAPPED RESILIENCY. POPULIST
OBVIOUSLY THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT.
AND OUR ABILITY TO ADAPT TO
CLIMATE BUT WE ALSO WITH THE
UPDATE OF OUR SCOPING PLAN.
WE ALSO HAVE ADOPTED A STRATEGY
AROUN NATURAL WORKING
LANDSCAPES.
WHICH IS A CRITICAL NEW STRATEGY
BECAUSE THAT ABILITY TO MANAGE.
AND TO APPLY MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES ON OUR LAND TO
SEQUESTER CARBON GIVES US A
CHANCE TO MEDICATE IT'S THE ONLY
WAY TO MEDICAID CLIMATE. AND BE
THOSE CARBON SINKS TO
QUESTION CARBON SO I WANTED TO
TOUCH VERY BRIEFLY ON THE
PROGRAMS THAT CDFA.
IT'S BEEN ABLE TO FUND WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE INVESTMENT
DOLLARS. AND IS A PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE AMOUNT OF MONEY OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IN THAT DEPTH OF THE DROUGHT WE
CREATED THE STATEWIDE WATER
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM WHICH IS ALL
ABOUT ON FARM WATER USE
EFFICIENCY. THAT WILL IMPROVE
THE EFFICIENT USE OF WATER
REDUCE WATER USE REDUCE ENERGY
USE AND THEREFORE REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
OVER FIVE HUNDRED PROJECTS OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES WITH
REAL WATER SAVINGS AND REAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS OVERSUBSCRIBED BY
THREE HUNDRED PERCENT.
SO WE ARE VERY PLEASED THAT
THERE ARE SOME FUNDING FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT'S IN THE BOND THAT
WILL BE ON ON THE BALLOT AND WE
HOPE THAT THAT PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE GREENHOUSE
GAS INVESTMENT DOLLARS.
BUT NEITHER PROGRAM THAT HAS
GOTTEN A LOT OF ATTENTION AND IT
IS A SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM IS FOR
OUR TERRY'S WE HAVE ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DAIRY COWS IN THE
STATE. WE WANT TO REDUCE METHANE
WAS A SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS. AND WE HAVE FUNDED
DAIRY DIE TESTERS THAT ARE
CREATING RENEWABLE ENERGY.
EITHER ELECTRICITY FOR THE FARM
ITSELF
I TAKE.
TAKE A LOAD OFF THE BREAD BUT
VERY EXCITINGLY THE ABILITY TO
GENERATE RENEWABLE. NATURAL GAS
TO HEAT OUR HOMES AND TO RUN
HOPEFULLY AS A LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION FUEL. THE TRUCKS
AND BIG EQUIPMENT GOING UP AND
DOWN THE CENTRAL VALLEY HIGHWAYS
I THINK THAT'S AN EXCITING NEW
OPPORTUNITY WE NEED SOME
STABILITY AND CERTAINTY IN THOSE
PROGRAMS AS WE PROTRACTED. MORE
DEVELOPERS TO COME INTO THIS.
BUT THE DAIRY SECTOR HAS STEPPED
UP AND CALIFORNIA GOING FROM
THREE JERRY DIED TESTERS A FEW
SHORT YEARS AGO TO BEING THE
NUMBER ONE STATE AND NOTHING
REDUCTION IS A PRETTY LAUDABLE.
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT WE ALSO HAVE
AN ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM WHICH FITS IN VERY
NICELY WITH AN INTEGRATED
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT APPROACH.
WHERE WE CAN USE THAT WHAT WE
USED TO THINK OF AS WASTE? AS
SOMETHING THAT HAS VALUABLE
NUTRIENTS IN AT HOW CAN WE DO A
SEPARATION HOW DO WE CAN WE GET
THAT INTO COMPOSTING. BUT AT THE
OTHER BYPRODUCTS COULD BE
CREATED WITH S. AND COULD BE
MOVED TO AREAS THAT ARE.
NUTRIENT.
DEFICIT ADDED AND GET IT OUT OF
AREAS WHERE THEY THEY HAVE AT. A
LARGE BALANCES THAT
SO THAT PROGRAM FITS VERY
NICELY%
WITH A HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM
WHICH IS AN EXCITING PROGRAM
THAT REALLY IS ABOUT WHAT OF
THOSE PRACTICES THAT WE COULD
PUT ON THE GROUND TO SEQUESTER
CARBON. AND INCREASE THE CARBON
IN OUR SOILS THE ORGANIC MATTER
IN OUR SOILS SO THAT THEY CAN
RETAIN MORE WATER. AND HELP WITH
GOOD PRODUCTIVITY FOR PLANTS
IT'S AN EXCITING NEW PROGRAM WE
JUST STARTED THAT LAST YEAR WE
HAVE OVER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GRANTS OUT TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AROUND THE STATE. IT'S
ONE THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
EXPANDING UM AND A TREMENDOUS
KIND OF WAY.
THOSE ARE JUST PART OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING FUNDED
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE INVESTMENT
DOLLARS WE ALSO AS YOU KNOW
MADAM CHAIR FROM SERVING ON THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL. FOR
TWO YEARS IN A ROW NOW WE'VE HAD
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS GOING INTO
FARMLAND CONSERVATION GRANTS
THOSE OUR EASEMENT PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE VERY VERY POPULAR
PEOPLE CARE PASSIONATELY ABOUT
THE LAND BEING ABLE TO KEEP BUT
IN AGRICULTURE AND IN THE FAMILY
AND THOSE HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL CROWDS.
THIS PAST YEAR WE ALSO.
HAD SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS MADE AVAILABLE TO HELP OUR
FOOD PROCESSING SECTOR IMPROVE
ITS ENERGY EFFICIENCY. AND I
JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT KEEPING
THE CROPS IN THE STATE IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT AND KEEPING
THE ABILITY TO PROCESS THEM AND
PROXIMITY TO WHERE THEY'RE BEING
CROWNED. IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT SO
REALLY PARTNERING WITH THE FOOD
PROCESSING SECTOR.
TO HELP THEM BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND TO IMPROVE THEIR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IS AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM FOR CONTINUED SUPPORT
AND I WOULD. HOPE THAT YOU ALL
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT AS I'M SURE THAT YOU DO.
I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
CHANCE TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY BUT
I WANT TO CLOSE WITH A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS.
CDF PHASE HISTORIC MISSION HAS
BEEN TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE FROM INVASIVE PASS.
AND PLANT AND ANIMAL DISEASES
THAT'S A CORE MISSION OF WHAT WE
DO IT IS NOT THE ONLY THING THAT
WE DO. CLIMATE CHANGE HAS A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THAT. IN
TWENTY ELEVEN I CONVENED A
CLIMATE CHANGE CONSORTIUM AROUND
SPECIALTY CROPS AND WE LAID OUT
A ROADMAP OF WHERE THE RESEARCH
NEEDS ARE. AND WHERE WE
ANTICIPATE THE NEED FOR US TO
ADAPT ON OUR FARMS.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE HAS A LOT
AT STAKE FROM CLIMATE CHANGE SO
WE REALLY NEED TO INVEST AND
HELPING THEM. ADAPT WITH NEW
PLANT BREEDING PROGRAMS AND ALL
THE OTHER THINGS GO WITHOUT.
WE ALSO.
AS PART OF AGRICULTURE HAVE
DEFIED THE PURPOSE OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE WHICH WE ALL
INTUITIVELY NOW BUT WOULD NEVER
PUT IT INTO A PURPOSE STATEMENT
IN AG FISSION.
THAT THE PURPOSE OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE IS TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A BETTER PLACE TO
LIVE BECAUSE OF WHAT WE TROUT.
AND HOW WE PER HOUR.
WE HAVE SOMETHING HERE.
THAT IS NOT EASILY FOUND IN
OTHER PLACES THIS HEALTHY
NUTRITIOUS FOOD SOURCE THAT'S
LITERALLY IN OUR BACKYARD WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO THAT
HEALTHY FOOD.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUR
STANDARDS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. AND LABOR PROTECTION
ARE SOME OF THE HIGHEST IN THE
WORLD IF NOT THE HIGHEST IN THE
WORLD AND THAT JUSTIFIES EVERY
CALIFORNIANS WANTED TO SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA GROWN FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS SO WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE WE
DEFINITELY HAVE OUR CHALLENGES.
WATER AND LABOR LEAD THAT BUT
THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SECRETARY
FOR BEING HERE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR.
BROAD VIEW IT'S IT'S AND IT I
MEAN I TOOK SOME NOTES HERE AND
IT'S INCREDIBLE EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON OVER THE.
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS AND.
SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IN AGRICULTURE THAT.
REALLY I THINK ARE PART OF OUR
GOAL TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
AND TO.
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PRODUCE
A GOOD HIGH QUALITY.
.
PRODUCE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE BECAUSE YOU'VE DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB QUINCY IF ANYBODY
IN THE COMMITTEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS.
NOW I THINK I THINK.
WHERE YOU HAVE LOT TO THINK
ABOUT?
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TODAY AND AND KIND OF GIVING US
AN OVERVIEW AT ME GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY AS WE DO OUR WORK TO
REALLY FOCUS AND THEN. AND
DUMPED.
AND DIG DEEP IN ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AND THESE ISSUE AREAS AS
WE START SPENDING GREENHOUSE
GAS.
OF DOLLARS AND.
MAKING SURE I'M ALL OF US ON
HERE ARE REALLY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING AGRICULTURE IN THE
STATE.
SO ALL MY.
WE KNOW THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME LIKE TO
NOW.
INVITE.
GLENDALE HUMUS TEN WHO IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES TO.
GIVE US MORE INFORMATION.
GREAT.
THANK YOU COULD CHAIRMAN OF
CHAIR OF THE EURO AND AND GOOD
AFTERNOON TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY MIGHT MY
NAME IS GOING TO HOUSTON. I'M
CURRENTLY SERVING AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WHICH
ALL REFERRED IN THIS IS A AND
ARE.
YOU SEE A IN OUR IS A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF HUNDREDS OF UC
RESEARCHERS AND EDUCATORS
PROVIDING SCIENCE BASED
INFORMATION TO FAMILIES FARMERS.
RANCHERS NATURAL RESOURCE
MANAGERS COMMUNITIES AND
POLICYMAKERS I ACTUALLY HAVE A
COUPLE DOCUMENTS THAT.
WOULD LIKE THE THE COMMITTEE TO
HAVE THAT ALL REFER TO.
THEN I'LL DO SOME HIGHLIGHTS IN
MY PREPARED REMARKS.
ONE IS A.
BUT ANNUAL REPORT THAT WE JUST
PUT UP FOR THE FIRST TIME THE
SHERIFFS ARE TEMPTED ONE I'M
SURE BE BETTER NEXT YEAR BUT WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE
DIVERSITY OF THE RESEARCH AND
THE. DELIVERY OF PROGRAMS
HAPPENING THROUGH THE STATE OF
WHAT YOU'LL SEE IN THIS IS OUR
SIX
STRATEGIC INITIATIVES WITH JUST
A FEW VIGNETTES OF DELIVERABLES.
WE LITERALLY HAVE THOUSANDS OF
RESEARCH PROJECTS GOING ON AT
ANY GIVEN MOMENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BUT OUR SIX STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES INCLUDE UP ONES
AROUND ENDEMIC IN INVASIVE PESTS
AND DISEASE WHICH WE JUST HEARD
SECRETARY ROSS SPEAKS SO ABLY
ABOUT. HEALTHY FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES
SUSTAINABLE FOOD SYSTEMS.
SUSTAINABLE NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS.
WATER QUALITY QUANTITY AND
SECURITY.
AND THEN SUSTAINABLE ENERGY.
THESE ARE INITIATIVES THAT WE
HAVE A WIDE ARRAY OF WORK GROUPS
AND PROGRAM TEAMS ARE
COORDINATING RESEARCH AROUND.
BUT IN IN A BROADER SENSE.
WE ARE REALLY THE PUBLIC
SERVICE ARM AT OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH RESEARCHERS ON SEVERAL
CAMPUSES AND NEARLY EVERY COUNTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ALL ARE A IN OUR SCIENTISTS ARE
ENGAGED IN THE FULL RANGE OF
BASIC TO APPLIED SCIENCE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH FARMERS. GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND OTHER PARTNERS TO
DISK
DISCOVER AND DELIVER SOLUTIONS.
THEY IN ARE TRULY IS THE FACE OF
YOU SEE FOR HUNDREDS. OF
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THE THE ONE PAGE OF DOCUMENTS
I'VE GIVEN YOU WAS AN ATTEMPT TO
GIVE YOU JUST AN OVERVIEW OF THE
NUMBERS THEMSELVES. UP AS YOU
CAN SEE WE HAVE OFFICES IN ALL
BUT TWO COUNTIES.
ALPINE COUNTY IN SAN FRANCISCO
HOWEVER BOTH OF THOSE COUNTIES
ARE SERVED FROM NEIGHBORING
OFFICES.
ADVISERS IN THOSE COUNTIES WORK
WITH A WIDE ARRAY OF PROGRAMS OR
RESEARCH EXTENSION CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO HOST
HUNDREDS OF RESEARCH PROJECTS.
AND THEN OUR AGRICULTURAL
EXPERIMENT STATION HAS SEVERAL
HUNDRED RESEARCHERS AND OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED RESEARCH
PROJECTS AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT.
THIS IS PART OF THE LAND GRANT
UNIVERSITY MISSION OF CALIFORNIA
ON THE BACK OF THAT YOU'LL SEE A
LISTING OF OUR STATEWIDE
PROGRAMS AND INSTITUTES.
AND AYE PITIFULLY ONE HIGHLIGHT
THE.
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE VOLUNTEERS
WE HAVE OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS WORKING WITH FOR H.
MASTER GARDENERS MASTER FOOD
PRESERVERS AND ARE CALIFORNIAN
NATURALIST.
ABOUT ONE OF THE NEWEST PROGRAMS
THE CALIFORNIA NATURALS IS
CURRENTLY PUTTING TOGETHER IS
SOMETHING CALLED CLIMATE
STEWARDS WERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
GIVING MORE CITIZENS BOTH ADULTS
AND YOUTH. OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENGAGE IN CITIZEN SCIENCE
AROUND.
.
UP CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE BOTTOM IS A SNAPSHOT OF OUR
PAST YOUR SPUN SOURCES AND USES
WHICH IS IN THE ANNUAL REPORT
BUT IT'S A LITTLE EASIER TO READ
ON THAT ONE PAGE JOURNAL LARGER.
.
PART COUNTY BASED COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION ADVISORS WORK WITH
TEAMS OF NON ACADEMIC STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS TO DELIVER THE
SERVICES THROUGH PROGRAMS SUCH
AS FOR AGE AND OF INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT MASTER GARDENERS
AND OUR STATE WIDE WATER
RESEARCH INSTITUTE.
A IN OURS COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
ADVISORS OR THE UC SCIENTISTS TO
WORK IN THE FIELD THEY GET DIRT
UNDER THEIR FINGERNAILS AND
HAVE.
HELP FARMERS AND RANCHERS SOLVE
REAL WORLD PROBLEMS.
WE HAVE ADVISERS THAT SPECIALIZE
IN IRRIGATION EFFICIENCY CLIMATE
CHANGE PEST MANAGEMENT AND
NUTRITION AS WELL AS DOZENS OF
OTHER TOPICS.
WE CAN ANSWER QUESTIONS ON HOW
TO CULTIVATE THE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED COMMODITIES GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO HELP MANAGE
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL RESOURCES A
LARGE PROJECT RECENTLY HAS BEEN
FLOODING OF FARMLAND TO IMPROVE
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE.
MORE RECENTLY A FACT UP THE CASE
OF WHERE WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY ON PRE FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS. DURING
THE DISASTER THEMSELVES ONE OF
THE FIRST CALLS THAT GO OUT
DURING A NATURAL DISASTER SUCH
AS THE RECENT FIRES IS TO OUR
FOUR H. CLUBS.
WHEN OF PETS AND LIVESTOCK OR
EVACUATED FROM A DISASTER AREA
TO THE FAIRGROUNDS OR FOR EIGHT
YEARS OF THE ONE TO TAKE CARE OF
THOSE ANIMALS ARE AS WE
PARTICULARLY SAW ON RIVERSIDE
CINEMA COUNTIES RECENTLY.
IN JANUARY.
.
EIGHT BILLION ARE AND CDFA HER
CO HOST OF AN INVASIVE SPECIES
SUMMIT HERE IN THIS BUILDING.
THIS WAS DESIGNED TO BRING
TOGETHER VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SCIENTIST.
TO CREATE A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
INVASIVE SPECIES PREVENTION
PROGRAM THE FINAL REPORT ON THAT
IS NEARLY READY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SHARING THAT WITH
YOU.
THERE'S A SERIOUS NEED TO
PREVENT INVASIVE SPECIES
INTRODUCTION AND SPREAD
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. EVERY
FIVE WEEKS A NEW PEST IS
ENTERING CALIFORNIA EVERY FIVE
WEEKS IT'S KIND OF FRIGHTENING I
USED TO JOKE THAT THERE WAS A
NEW BOOK EVERY MONTH. AND I GOT
CORRECTED THAT IT WAS FIVE WEEKS
I I ACTUALLY THOUGHT I WAS
JOKING TO BE HONEST. BOOKED OUT
IT IS TRULY FIVE WEEKS
WE'RE CURRENTLY FIGHTING ASIAN
CITRUS SALUTE AND LONG LONG
BEING WHICH IS DEVASTATING THE
SICK PERSON INTEREST DRAIN
FLORIDA AND WE'RE DOING OUR BEST
TO. NOT HAVE THAT HAPPEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND AND DISEASES THAT
ARE JUST AFFECTING ADD ONE OF
THE BIG BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING
WITH RIGHT NOW DOWN IN THE
ORANGE LA RIVERSIDE COUNTY AREA.
IS SHOT HOLE BORDER WHICH IS
DEVASTATING URBAN FOREST AND
COULD POTENTIALLY JUMP INTO THE
AVOCADO SECTOR.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT OUR
WORK TO SUPPORT INNOVATION AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IN OUR RURAL
SECTOR PARTICULARLY AROUND AG
TECHNOLOGY.
A IN OUR IS CONNECTING
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD VALLEY'S WAS
SILICON VALLEY TO ALIGN CAPITAL
INVESTMENT WITH REAL WORLD
NEEDS.
RECENTLY A IN OUR RECEIVED A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
GRANT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE'S ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. TO CREATE THE VINE THE
VERDE INNOVATION NETWORK FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
THE VINE CONNECTS ENTREPRENEUR
STATEWIDE WITH FOOD AG AND
NATURAL RESOURCE EXPERTS AND IS
CATALYZING THE SUPPORT TO TAKE
IDEAS TO COMMERCIALIZATION.
WE EXPECT THAT THESE CONNECTIONS
WILL CATALYZE INNOVATION THAT
WILL REVOLUTIONIZE CURRENT
FARMING IN CONSERVATION
PRACTICES WERE ALSO WORKING WITH
A WIDE ARRAY OF BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERS. TO
DEVELOP AN AG TECHNOLOGY
INSTITUTE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH CDFA.
FOR INSTANCE A FEW EXAMPLES OF
WHAT WE'VE GOT GOING ON IS WE
NOW CAN USE DRONES TO DETECT
PEST DAMAGE ON CROPS SO THAT
PESTICIDES MAY BE APPLIED
QUICKLY AND MUCH MORE
STRATEGICALLY. TO THE AFFECTED
AREA RATHER THAN AN ENTIRE
FIELD.
SCIENTISTS AND ENTREPRENEURS
HAVE ALSO DEVELOP PRECISION AG
TECHNOLOGY THAT AMONG OTHER
BENEFITS.
GREATLY REDUCE WATER USE AN
INCREASE YIELDS.
MANY OF THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
REQUIRE CLOUD COMPUTING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
BROADBAND ACCESS SO THAT DATA
MAY BE UPLOADED AND DOWNLOADED
FROM THE FIELD. AND PROCESSED
INTO USABLE ACTIONS
I RECENTLY TESTIFIED ON THIS
TOPIC BEFORE THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE A COPY OF MY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO ANY INTERESTED
MEMBERS.
PROVIDING BROADBAND ACCESS AND
RURAL AREAS WILL ALSO BRING
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY TO LOCAL
RESIDENTS.
ALLOWING FOR IMPROVED QUALITY OF
LIFE IN SOME AREAS SOME OF THE
MOST IMPOVERISHED AREAS OF THE
STATE.
HIGH SPEED INTERNET ACCESS IS
THE GATEWAY TO ONLINE EDUCATION
TELEHEALTH AND OTHER IMPORTANT
SERVICES.
ONE EXAMPLE OF A CITIZEN SCIENCE
PROJECT WE ARE CURRENTLY
ORGANIZING WITH OUR FOUR H.
YOUTH IS TO ASSIST THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. IMPROVING THE MAPS
OF WHAT THE BROADBAND ACCESS AND
QUALITY IS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES TO GET
FUNDING IN MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE IS THAT THERE ISN'T REALLY
GOOD MAPPING.
THE CP YOU SEE IS DEVELOPED AN
APP FOR THE PHONE CALLED CAL
SPEED WE'RE HAVING ALL OF OUR
FOR H. MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE DOWNLOAD THAT. AND DURING
THE WEEK THIS SUMMER THEY'LL BE
RUNNING TESTS SEVERAL TIMES A
DAY FOR A WEEK THAT WILL.
DOCUMENT HOW GOOD THE UPLOAD
DOWNLOAD SPEED IS THE QUALITY OF
THE SIGNAL GEO REFERENCE THAT
AND SHIP IT STRAIGHT TO THE
CPUC.
AND THEN THEY AND ARE IN
INFORMATICS AND SHOULD BE AYE
YES MAPPING A STATEWIDE PROGRAM
WORK TOGETHER WITH THEM.
TO OUR IMPROVE THOSE MAPS AND
USE THEM TO HELP TARGET
INVESTMENTS AND OTHER RESOURCES
TO IMPROVE THAT.
IT'S EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE MANY
CITIZEN SCIENCE PROJECT WHERE
EXPANDING RIGHT NOW FOR BOTH OUR
YOUTH AND ADULTS.
WE'RE ALSO VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT PROVISIONS TO CREATE SMART
FORMS AND AND THE DISCUSSION ON
THAT AT THE YOU SEE SEE ISSUE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND
FAIRGROUNDS. IN FACT A IN OUR
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR SOME TIME
TO EXPAND OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE CSU SYSTEM AND OUR COLLEGES.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE PURSUING SOME
OPPORTUNITIES IN FACT.
.
ONE THING THAT HAS BAFFLED ME
SINCE THE DAY I TOOK THIS
POSITION WAS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
A RESEARCH EXTENSION CENTER IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY. WHICH SEEMS
VERY WRONG ON MANY LEVELS.
OF NOT HAVING THE TWENTY OR
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO SET
SUCH A THING UP.
THE PRESIDENT APART NO
COMMUNICATIVE GIN I ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN PARTNER
WITH THEIR LAND AND FACILITIES
UC RESEARCHERS AND THE USDA
FACILITY THERE. TO CREATE THE
FIRST EVER YOU SEE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE RESEARCH EXTENSION
CENTER.
IT NOT ONLY WILL FACILITATE
THAT KIND OF RESEARCH I'VE BEEN
DESCRIBING ALREADY BUT WILL GIVE
THOSE COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENTS
OFF WIDE ARRAY OF NEW CAREER
PATHS TO BE LOOKING AT AND AND
HAVING EXPERIENCE WITH.
WE'RE ALSO VERY EXCITED ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES ON COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS.
WE SEE THEM AS A CRUCIAL PIECE
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
ROLE CALIFORNIA AND HAVE SEVERAL
PROJECTS IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN ACTUALLY USING THEM AS THE
SITES OF INCUBATORS A MAKER LABS
AND. OPPORTUNITIES TO HOST
ENTREPRENEURS.
WITH THAT I WILL WRAP UP MY
COMMENTS BY REITERATING THAT YOU
SEE A IN OUR IS HERE TO PROVIDE
RESEARCH EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
SERVICE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THIS YEAR YOU SEE IS CELEBRATING
ITS CESCO CENTENNIAL.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS.
I LIKE TO SAY THAT A IN ART IS
THE ORIGINAL INCUBATOR AND THE
TECH SUPPORT FOR FARMERS AND
RANCHRS BRINGING SCIENCE AND
INNOVATION TO WORLD WAR. REAL
WORLD PROBLEMS FOR THESE PAST
FOR A ONE HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
NEXT ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS
AS WELL AND PARTNERING WITH YOU
ON THAT.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND I
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING
SOME QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
THAT WIDE SCOPE OF OF THINGS
THAT THE UC IS INVOLVED IN AND
YOUR WORK AT YOU SEE AN ARMS
BEEN TRICKED TREMENDOUS.
AND AND TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL
FOR THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
WE'VE LOOKED AT A ISSUES ALL
OVER THE STATE.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER MISTER.
KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK AND THAT
LET'S GET THAT.
A FACILITY GOING IN SALINAS I
LIKE. THE IDEA I MEAN WE WHEN
YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT IT IT'S
ONE OF THE MOST PRODUCTIVE.
VALLEYS IN IN THE STATE AND TO
NOT HAVE A A RESEARCH
INSTITUTION THEY'RE OUT WORKING
WITH PART NOW COLLEGE IS THAT.
THE IT OVERSIGHT IT THEY'RE
DOING SOME TREMENDOUS WORK AT
THEIR THEIR COULD PARTNER.
ACTUALLY THE FACILITY WE HAVE
DOWN IN THE VENTURA SANTA
BARBARA AREA IS NOT ADEQUATE
EITHER WERE PARTNERING THERE
WERE LOOKING APARTMENT THERE WAS
CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS. AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE KIND OF
PARTNERSHIPS ALL OVER THE STATE
BECAUSE I REALLY THINK THAT'S
HOW WE BETTER LEVERAGE OUR
FINITE RESOURCES AND BETTER
SERVE OUR CITIZENS ON EVERY
SINGLE REGION HAS. THE CLAIM
IT'S DIFFERENT THE SOILS
DIFFERENT BUT THE CROPS THAT ARE
BEING GROWN ARE DIFFERENT SO TO
pLOOK AT THAT AND TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE. BEST SOLUTIONS ARE
FOR INCREASING YIELD AND
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC AND THAT'S
I THINK A REALLY IMPORTANT UP
OPPORTUNITY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE YOUR. TESTIMONY. AND.
WAT THAT WILL MOVE ON TO OUR?
?
AGENDA.
AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO START A SUCH
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE NEED A QUORUM AND WE WERE
CLOSE AND THEN WE LOST IT SO
WELL WE'LL GET IT BACK AYE AYE
YEAH I REMAIN CONFIDENT. I'M IN.
IF THERE ARE THERE A LOT OF
COMMITTEES AND.
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE JUST GOING TO
TAKE OUR TIME AND DO IT RIGHT SO
LET ME JUST SAY THAT IN TO IN
REGARDS TO THE AGENDA TODAY. OUT
WE HAD EIGHT ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY NINE BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR AUTHOR
WILL BE HEARD TODAY. PUMP
EXPECT.
IT MAY COME BACK.
SO WORLD WILL MOVE ON IN OUR
AGENDA. TO WALT WILL TAKE UP
THAN THE NON.
COMMITTEE MEMBER AGENDA ITEMS
AND I DON'T SEE ANYBODY HERE.
SO YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ASKED
WE HAVE. SO.
SO I GUESS WHAT WE OUGHT TO
START DOING IS CALLING.
THE ABSENT
INDIVIDUALS.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY
HERE. I CAN DO MY OWN MISTER
LEVINE.
PERFECT TIMING
.
THOSE WHO MAKE THEIR TIME.
MR LEVINE LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
YOU'RE UP.
I'M IF WE COULD CALL ITEM NUMBER
SIX ON THE AGENDA WITCHES AB
TWENTY EIGHT TEN.
SON GROWN CANNABIS COMMISSION.
SOUNDS GET.
I THINK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT.
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT TEN
WHICH WOULD CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA SUN GROWN CANNABIS
COMMISSION SINCE THE EARLY
SEVENTIES THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE'S VOTED AUTHORIZED
THE CREATION OF MORE THAN. NINE
OUT TWENTY FIVE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONS TODAY NINETEEN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE INDUSTRY THERE ARE THERE ARE
PRESENT. PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
MADE CANNABIS A LEGAL CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT THE SUN
GROWN CANNABIS FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN
ANY OTHER FORMER UN I REPRESENT.
THEY'RE CONCERNED WITH MARKET
SHARE GOVERNMENT REGULATION
COSTS IN SUSTAINABILITY AND
TODAY MANY ARE CONCERNED WITH
THEIR VERY SURVIVAL. THE
COMMISSION CREATED BY THIS BILL
WILL REPRESENT OUTDOOR CANNABIS
FARMERS I AND II WITH WITH
EITHER AN OUTDOOR. OR MIXED
LIGHT LICENSE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE THE
TRADITIONAL SMALL FAMILY
OPERATIONS MANY WHICH HAVE BEEN
FARMING FOR DECADES
IF APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND SIGNED INTO LAW THE SUN
GROWN COMMISSION WILL ONLY TAKE
EFFECT UPON A SUCCESSFUL VOTE.
OF THOSE PRODUCERS INCLUDED IN
THE DEFINITION THE COMMISSION
WILL HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
ESTABLISH OFFICES HIRE STAFF
PROVIDE FOR EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. CONTRACT FOR
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES IN REPRESENTS
GROWERS BEFORE LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS
THESE FARMERS A NUMBER OF WHOM
ARE HERE TODAY POPE TO BUILD
UPON. THE SUCCESS OF OTHER
FARMERS INTRIGUING ENTITY THAT
HELPS THEM SURVIVE IN A VERY
COMPETITIVE MARKETPLACE I WANTED
TO READ. THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS
OF THE COMMISSION WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION FOR WHY WANTED NOW
ALSO PRESENT TO YOU.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS REPRESENTING INDOOR
CANNABIS GROWERS AS WELL.
AND THEY HAVE ASKED IF I WOULD
INCLUDE IN THIS LEGISLATION. AN
INDOOR CANNABIS COMMISSION AS
WELL THAT IS INDEPENDENT FROM
THE SUN GROWN CANNABIS
COMMISSION AND DISTINCT AND SO I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU.
THAT I DECIDED THAT WE JUST
AGREED TO.
MOMENTS AGO BUT THAT I'D
COMMITTED TO THEM TO DO DIED TO
DIE REMOVE OPPOSITION AND TO
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR THIS
LEGISLATION.
THE THE BREAKING IT IS. SO.
YEAH SO THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS FOR THE SUN GROWN
CANNABIS COMMISSION.
I HAVE WORKED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
OUT REPRESENTING INDOOR
CANNABIS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND.
AND SO THEY HAVE ASKED OF ME
AND I'VE COMMITTED TO THEM TO
INCLUDE IN THIS LEGISLATION AN
INDOOR CANNABIS COMMISSION THAT
WOULD SUPPORT.
THAT THE PROFESSIONALISM AND
PROFESSIONALIZATION.
OF THAT FORMING ENTITY THE SAME
WAY THAT THE SUN GOING CANNABIS
COMMISSION WOULD. THE INTERESTS
OF THE TWO DIFFERENT GROUPS ARE.
LONG TERM VERY SIMILAR BUT SHORT
TERM AS A.
BECOME REGULATED BECOME
LICENSED BECOME PROFESSIONAL AYE
IS BUT THEY ARE UNIQUE AND THAT
IS SENT OUT IN A SENSE WHY
OTHERS IN THE FOR THE TWO
SEPARATE COMMISSIONS.
OKAY I'M SORRY FOR THE SURPRISE
IT IT WAS A BIT OF A SURPRISE TO
ME TOO.
SO SO I AM APPRECIATE. IT THAT
THIS I CONCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IF I COULD JUST TAKE A BREAK RA
QUICKEN TAKE ROLL CALL. SOUNDS
GET IN AT ALL INTEREST WITH US
OKAY ACCOUNTS GOOD.
THE ROLL CALL PLEASE
COMEY ARE OUT HERE APPAREL HERE
MATHIS HERE MATHIS HERE AGUILAR
CURRY. FLORA. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER HERE GRAY EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE.
GRAY HERE JONES SAWYER. LEVINE.
HERE LIVING HERE SALAS ROSA.
SALAS HERE CORONARY WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. SO YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WITH ME IN
SUPPORT TODAY OF AB TWENTY
TENNIS CHRISTIAN OF IT ALL
PRESIDENT THE INTERNATIONAL
CANNABIS FARMERS ASSOCIATION AND
A FORMER HERSELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HAS SOME COMMENTS PREPARED SO.
AS PENSION MANY MISS KRISTEN OF
ALL.
AYE A LIVING CARGO CALIFORNIA
AND I AM A LONG TIME MEDICAL
CANNABIS FARMER MYSELF BECAUSE
ONE OF THE CO FOUNDERS OF THE
EMERALD GROWERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
SERVE ON THE CALIFORNIA CANVAS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. AND SEPARATE US CCA'S
AGRICULTURAL.
COMMITTEE CHAIR.
I AM THE FOUNDING CHAIR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL CANVAS FARMERS
ASSOCIATION IN SHORT I HAVE
DEDICATED MOST OF MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE TO PROMOTING
BEST PRACTICES FOR SOME GROWN
CANNABIS FARMERS. AND A HEALTHY
SAFE AND SUSTAINABLE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. EARLY ONE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
ABOUT A SON GROWN CANNABIS
COMMISSION.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
NUMEROUS QUESTIONS WHICH ON YOU
KNOW ALL OF THIS IS KIND OF A
SURPRISE TO ME TOO. BUT ABOUT
WHY.
TO SEPARATE A COMMISSIONS WOULD
BE NECESSARY.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TWO SEPARATE AG
COMMISSIONS.
THE PRIMARY REASONS FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SON GROWN A
COMMISSION VERSUS AN ALL
INCLUSIVE AG COMMISSION. REALLY
IS THE FACT THAT OUT TORN MIX
LATE TIER ONE FARMERS WHICH
WOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE SUN
GROWN A COMMISSION.
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT MEANS IN
THE INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY NOR ARE
THEY SUBJECT TO.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
REGULATIONS BOTH OF THESE PIECES
ARE NOT ONLY INCREDIBLY ONEROUS
BUT INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE TUCSON
GROUND FARMERS MANY OF WHOM.
ALSO FARM ON THE LAND IN WHICH
THEY LIVE ON THEIR FARM IN THEIR
HOME STATES.
AND SO WHILE SOME GROUND
CULTIVATORS BASED ON THE
STATE'S.
OF OUR PIR POTENTIALLY MAKE UP
EIGHTY PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
CULTIVATORS CURRENTLY THEY ONLY
RECOGNIZE ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT
OF THE MARKET SHARE. SO WHILE WE
ARE THE UNDERDOG IN MANY WAYS.
WE ARE ALSO THE MOST HEAVILY
REGULATED AND SPENDING THE MOST
MONEY TO TRY TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE IN A REGULATED
MARKETPLACE.
ADDITIONALLY THE RESEARCH NEEDS
OF SOME GROUND CULTIVATORS ARE
VASTLY DIFFERENT FROM THE
RESEARCH NEEDS OF INDOOR MIX
LATER TO CULTIVATORS. ON THE
RESEARCH THAT WE REALLY NEED IS
A ASSISTANCE IN DEVELOPING AN
APPELLATION OF ORIGIN ON
ASSISTANCE IN IN SHARING NOT OUR
ACTIVITIES.
BECOME MORE SUSTAINABLE ON
LEAVE A SMALLER FOOTPRINT AND
ENCOURAGE DIVERSITY WITHIN OUR
WATER SHUTS.
THE RESEARCH THAT'S NEEDED FOR
INDOOR CULTIVATORS LARGELY AS A
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENT RIGHT
HOW CAN ENTER CULTIVATORS
RELYING ON HIGH INTENSITY
DISCHARGE LIGHTING TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CULTIVATE YEAR ROUND.
THIS IS GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
I'M MORE EFFICIENCY IS THE
TECHNOLOGICAL AREA SO THEY CAN
REDUCE THE CARBON FOOTPRINT
THAT'S OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH IN
HIGH INTENSITY DISCHARGE LIGHT
USAGE. TWO VERY DIFFERENT ENDS
OF THE SPECTRUM CLEARLY SON
SPECTRUM VERSUS LIGHTS PATTERN.
SO.
WE REALLY.
WANT TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ALL ASPECTS OF THE INDUSTRY
ARM WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT I AM.
AMONGST SOME GROUND CULTIVATORS
WE TEND TO BE THE SMALLEST
PRODUCERS IN THE STATE AND THEN
OF THE SUN GROWN CULTIVATOR THE
SPECIALTY COTTAGE HERE.
THEY ARE AT MOST RISK OF GOING
EXTINCT AND SO WE REALLY
SPECIFICALLY LOOK FORWARD TO.
HELPING THEM OUT WITH THE SUN
GROWN A COMMISSION WERE LOOKING
AT TIERED ASSESSMENTS. THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM THE ABILITY TO
REAP THE BENEFITS OF AND
PARTICIPATE IN A SUN GROWN A
COMMISSION WITHOUT NECESSARILY
HAVING TO PAY ASSESSMENTS. SO WE
WOULD SCALE THE ASSESSMENTS UPS
OF THE LARGER.
AND THE MORE YOU PRODUCE AS A
SIGN GROUND FARMER THE MORE
ASSESSMENT YOU PAYS SO IT HELPS
TO LIFT THE ENTIRE.
INDUSTRY OP AS IT GOES ON THE
LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY PRETTY
BOILERPLATE HATE OR WORKING ON.
NUMEROUS EVENTS TO GATHER
STAKEHOLDER INPUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE EMBODY THE NEEDS OF THE
SONOGRAM FARMERS.
WE HAVE HELD LISTENING%
ADVANCING UKIAH EUREKA SANTA
BARBARA AND MONTEREY SO FAR WILL
BE IN SAN RAFAEL ON FRIDAY. AND
THEN WE LOOK FORWARD TO DOING IT
ALL OVER AGAIN TO GET MORE INPUT
SO.
I REALLY THINK YOU FOR LETTING
ME TAKE THE TIME TO.
EXPRESS OUR NEEDS AND OUR
CONCERNS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT
SPELLING HOPES MOVE IT FORWARD
THINKING EVERY MATCH.
HI THANK YOU THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL ORTIZ AND I AM
ALSO A SMALL LICENSE HOLDER. AND
I'M COME FROM A MULTI
GENERATIONAL CANNABIS FAMILY UP
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M I
WAS BORN IN MENDOCINO IN THE
HEIGHT OF THE BACK TO THE LAND
MOVEMENT.
OF MY FAMILY DID NOT SURVIVE THE
DRUG WAR INTACT AND I SPENT MY
MOST OF MY CHILDHOOD IN
TRADITIONAL AGRICULTURE. MY MOM
TOOK US WITH HER LOVE FOR
AGRICULTURE INTO THE DESERT
SOUTHWEST WHERE SHE RAISED
VEGETABLE SEEDS AND CONTRACTED
FARMS FOR PRODUCTION. AND SO I
GREW UP IN A MORE TRADITIONAL
AGRICULTURE.
CITING A MY MOVE BACK TEHAMA
COUNTY TWENTY YEARS AGO AND I'M
A PART OF THAT CANNABIS CULTURE
AND THE BACK TO AND MOVEMENT
THAT EXISTS THERE STILL TO OUR
VALUES AND OUR. COMMUNITY. AND
SEE THROUGH THIS CHANGING
REGULATORY LANDSCAPE THAT SON
GROUND CANNABIS HAS MORE IN
COMMON WITH AGRICULTURE THAN IT
DOES WITH INDOOR CANNABIS WHILE
WE HAVE MANY SIMILARITIES WHERE
WE WILL COME TOGETHER. SANGRAM
CANNABIS FACES ALL THESE UNIQUE
REGULATORY NEEDS I DON'T NEED TO
GET INTO THEM SINCE SHE DID BUT
WE ON OURS SUPER TINY FARMS.
FACE THE TRADITIONAL SEASONAL
PROBLEMS SUCH AS RECENTLY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND FIRES AND MUD
SLIDES NEW PASS WE FACE.
RAINFALL ALL KINDS OF SEASONAL
CONSIDERATIONS AND JUST WORKING
WITHIN THAT WINDOW OF THE
NATURAL SEASONS IN ADDITION TO
FISH AND WILDLIFE REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD ROAD
ASSOCIATIONS AND ALL OF THESE
ADDITIONAL. SCHOOL BUS THAT
SETBACKS IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WE FACE.
I'M WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO
AMORTIZE THOSE COSTS
AND SO EVERYTHING THAT KAREN
ROSS SPOKE ON THIS MORNING WAS
DEAR TO OUR HEART WE TALK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE WE TALK ABOUT
CARBON SEQUESTRATION WE TALK
ABOUT. CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY AND
CALIFORNIA SUNSHINE AND HOW
BEAUTIFUL IT IS AND IT'S PART OF
OUR STORY. AND WANTING TO SEE
THAT SIGNED ON CULTIVATORS HAVE
A VEHICLE TO. TELL THAT STORY
WITHOUT THE INFLUENCE OF OTHER
INDUSTRY AND SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SUPPORT WE
WOULD SUPPORT THE CREATION OF
OTHER COMMISSIONS BUT IF WE
INCLUDED IN OUR IN OUR
COMMISSION IT WOULDN'T SERVE THE
PURPOSE OF WHAT WE HAD. WHAT WE
NEEDED SO THAT WAS MY PRIMARY
TALKING POINT TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS BEING HERE
AND I WOULD REALLY LOVE TO HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT AND COMMITTEE AND
WHAT?
GIVE THAT SUPPORT BACK TO YEAR
CONSTITUENTS TO GROW CANNABIS
WHERE THEY NEED TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS
BROWN I'M HERE PRIMARILY HERE
FOR TECHNICAL ISSUES INTO A.
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS IT RELATES
TO COMMISSIONS BUT I WILL LET
THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME. THAT YOU
WILL HAVE SEEN MULTIPLE
COMMISSIONS CREATED FOR ANY ONE
COMMODITY.
THE WINE INDUSTRY IS PROBABLY
THE BEST EXAMPLE THERE ARE FIVE
DIFFERENT COMMISSIONS IN LAW
DEALING WITH THE WINE INDUSTRY
HOW COUPLE OF THEM ARE MADE
MAYES MAINLY FOR GEOGRAPHICAL
REASONS. THE MENDOCINO ONE GREAT
COMMISSION ALONE I WOULD BRIDGE
ONE GREAT COMMISSION THE BACK IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX THREE
COMMISSIONS WERE CREATED IN ONE
YEAR. TWO OF THEM IN ONE BILL.
PRINCIPALLY BECAUSE THE
INDUSTRY WAS LOOKING FOR
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES AND TO
TRY TO FIND THE BEST FIT FOR THE
INDUSTRY SO YOU HAD THE
CALIFORNIA WINE GRAPE COMMISSION
YOU HAD THE WIND COMMISSION AND
THEN YOU HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
WINE AND WINE GREAT COMMISSION.
ALL ALL DETERMINE. IN.
DID TWO BILLS IN ONE YEAR SO
THIS IS NOT UNIQUE TO HAVE AN
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY OF THIS
NATURE HAS DIFFERENT CULTURAL
PRACTICES HAS DIFFERENT NEEDS
FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY SEE. LOOK
AT AND SEE TWO SEPARATE
COMMISSIONS TO SERVE THEIR
INTERESTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD IF YOU WOULD.
AND IF YOU CAN JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AND WHETHER YOU'RE IN SPORT
OR NOT. MEXICO COLONUS AYE WITH
KEISTER CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF
FLOW KANA IN SUPPORT OF BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TINA MARTIN WIDMANN
MADE FARMS AND.
I AM THE SON IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THINK YOU.
MY NAME'S ANDY*FROM
HUMBOLDT COUNTY WE'RE GONNA
BLISS FARMS AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS HAZEL BACK WELL I AM
WITH THE EMERALD CUP AND WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL HUNG Q..
MY NAME'S HEATHER BERG I'M A
PARTNER WITH THE LAW FIRM OF
GREENSPOON MARTYR AND NOT A
CULTIVATOR BUT I DO SUPPORT
CULTIVATORS. AND I AM STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS HOLLY CARTER AND
LIVING ROADWAY IN SOUTHERN
HUMBOLDT CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE.
HERTZBERG CONFLICTED OR NOT. AND
SAW A MARIN SEEN AT WITH CAPITA
STRATEGIES GROUP WHEN WE HAVE
THE THAT KIND OF HIS BUSINESS
ALLIANCE.
AND OUT WHITE THAT MISTER THE
VIENEN THE SPONSORS FOR
INCLUSION IN THERE ARE
COMMISSION AND THE BILL. AND WE
WE COMPLETELY AGREE THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS AND AND A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY RIGHT NOW AS WE TRY
TO GET THIS. I REGULATORY SYSTEM
UP PLACE THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T KNOW
WHO IS GOING TO AT.
MAKE IT IN THE LONG RUN SAW HOW
WE APPRECIATE IT WE WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER AND WE DO WANT TO SEE
THE SMALL OUTDOOR FARMER
SUCCEED.
AND AS I MENTIONED TO YOU WE
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED DISPENSARIES
WHAT COURT IN THEIR CULTIVATION
AND WE WANT TO HAVE THIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOU SO. WHAT
THAT MISTER RABIN'S COMMITMENT
WE'VE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF KHALIFA WERE BASED
IN SAN JOSE WHETHER IT VERY
LARGE CULTIVATION OPERATION
THERE AND WERE JUST AWARDED A
PERMIT IN MISTER SALAS DISTRICT
IN THE CITY OF HANFORD. FOR
CULTIVATION THERE AS WELL I'M WE
DID INDICATE OUR OPPOSITION ON
TO THE SINGLE COMMISSION IN OUR
LETTER TO YOU AND O THE TO THE
AUTHOR WITH HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
THEM. I'M WE LOVE THE IDEA OF A
COMMISSION WE THINK FOR THIS
GROWING INDUSTRY A COMMISSION IS
GOING TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT.
I'M STEP IN MAKING SURE THAT
THIS AYE INDUSTRIES PROFESSIONAL
LIES AND ULTIMATELY ONCE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GETS THEIR
ACT TOGETHER.
BE ABLE TO MARKET OURSELVES
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WE THINK THE IDEA OF A
COMMISSION IS A GREAT IDEA I'M
WE HAVE ADVOCATED FOR A SINGLE
COMMISSION.
WE ACTUALLY LIKE MISTER
LEVINE'S IDEA OF TWO COMMISSIONS
AND UNDERSTAND FROM MISTER
BROWN'S INPUT THAT.
WE WOULDN'T BE THE FIRST TO DO
THIS AND THERE ARE DIFFERENT
ISSUES HARPER EACH OF THOSE.
INDUSTRIES BUT THE ONE I ISSUE
THAT COMBINES ON FOR EVERYBODY
I'M IS THE ONE ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE PROFESSIONAL THAT
WERE MARKETING THAT. THAT WE ARE
MAKING THIS SITE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA AS STRONG
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN SO WE WOULD
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS MISTER LET ME JUST
TALK ABOUT MOVE TO SUPPORT
POSITION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT THAT.
HERE TO FOUR HAD AN OPPOSE
POSITION BUT.
IS RETHINKING IT OR YOU'RE STILL
POST.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THAT OKAY AYE
JASON RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
WANT TO THANK THE SPONSORS FOR
BRIEFING ORGANIZATION AT THAT
LENGTH LAST WEEK.
BUT WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO WHO
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE BILL WOULD
ALSO MEMBERS WHO HAVE CONCERNS
AND SO AS A RESULT THE
ORGANIZATION IS OFFICIALLY
NEUTRAL IN THE BILL WE LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE DISCUSSION WITH THE
OFF FROM THE SPONSORS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
VERY GOOD.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR BY THE
COMMISSION. COMMITTEE.
THE SAUCE.
THE GREATER CHAIRED I JUST THINK
MISTER LEVINE FOR MEETING WITH
EVERYBODY AND GOING THROUGH.
GOING THROUGH ALL THAT THE FINER
POINTS OF THAT THE LEGISLATION
BUT.
IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPLETELY UNDER YOUR DISCUSSION
BUT. IS THERE A WAY TO MAYBE PUT
THIS ITEM.
ON THE HEARING FOR THE TWENTY
FIFTH AS A VOTE ONLY SINCE WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT IT TODAY BUT MAYBE
WITH SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
FLUSHED OUT FROM.
FROM THE AUTHOR. THAT CAN BE
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS FOR
THE NEXT HEARINGS THAT WE CAN
JUST VOTE ON THAT.
BECAUSE I'D FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE SEEING.
EXACTLY WHAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
TO THE LEGISLATION.
I'LL BUT YOU KNOW SINCE WE DID
HEAR ABOUT IT TODAY PROFLIGATE
JUST TO VOTE ONLY ON. HUNTER
NEXT YEAR.
SO I'M I'M TOLD THAT THIS IS
BEEN DOUBLE REFERRED AND SO IT'S
GOT TO GO TO BMP I.
YEAH IT'S IT'S IT'S ESSENTIALLY
THE SAME BILL BUT TO NAMED
COMMISSIONS.
IT'S A VERY.
THEN CRUCIFY.
THE AUTHOR PERHAPS
SOMEONE ELSE COULD.
ARTICULATE FOR ME HOW OR WHEN WE
LOOK AT IT AS FAR AS LICENSED.
OUTDOOR CULTIVATORS.
VERSES LICENSE INDOOR
CULTIVATORS WHAT'S THE NUMBER
RIGHT NOW.
CALIFORNIA VERSUS UNLICENSED.
I'M SORRY NEED YEAH YEAH I THINK
THAT YOU MIGHT NEED TO GO TO.
THE NEW STATE AGENCY THAT.
THAT'S I MEAN YOU MIGHT IF YOU
DO KNOW THAT YOU'RE FREE TO GIVE
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE HERE
ACTUALLY HAS THAT NUMBER BECAUSE
IT'S CHANGING NUMBER. YEAH I I
DON'T THINK WE KNOW LICENSE
VERSES UNLICENSED APPLES TIME.
I DO KNOW THAT WE ARE EXPECTING.
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE LICENSED
OUTDOOR MIX LATE HERE ONE
CULTIVATORS TO COME ONLINE IN
HUMBLE COUNTY THEY DID JUST
ISSUE AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
HUNDRED PERMITS.
BUT. BEYOND THAT IT'S VERY HARD
TO QUANTIFY THE NUMBER OF SAY
UNLICENSED OPERATORS.
IN THE STATE RIGHT AND IN ONE
ONE THING THAT YOU KNOW IS WE'RE
LOOKING AT DATA THAT DOES COME
AND I THINK THAT THE REVENUES
BELOW PROJECTIONS AND I THINK
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THE BARRIER. TO A
MEETING THE REGULATORY.
STANDARDS THAT ARE ARE
NECESSARY FOR THAT LICENSE
SEEMED FOUR THEN. THE
WHOLESALERS AND RETAILERS TO
THEN DISTRIBUTE AND SELL IT.
AND DIE A LOT OF THEM ACTUALLY
BUY. EXTRA.
BEFORE JANUARY.
TO TO MEET THE NEED THAT THEY
HAD BECAUSE THEY HAD ANTICIPATED
THE REGULATORY HURDLE BEING ONE
THAT WAS SUBSTANTIAL.
AND.
THE HOPE IS FOR THESE
COMMISSIONS TO.
HELP.
GROWERS FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
BEST PRACTICES ARE AND HOW THE
PROFESSIONAL LIES SO THAT WE
CAN.
YOU KNOW.
HOW THE ONES THAT WERE IN
DISMISSING CAN MEET THOSE
REGULATIONS?
BE LICENSED
AN AND I THINK ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT PIECES OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING SPECIFICALLY WITH SOME
GROUND FARMERS RIGHT NOW IS
THERE FINING THAT THE. COST OF
REGULATION IS SO HIGH THAT
THEY'RE LOSING MONEY CURRENTLY.
THEY'RE HOPING THAT THEY CAN.
KIND OF MANAGE THE BLEEDING OF
THE HEMORRHAGING OF FUNDS UNTIL
THE MARKET BALANCES ITSELF OUT
WE GOT ON ENOUGH RETELL ENTITIES
ONLINE.
BUT.
WERE SUFFERING FROM FARMERS
ACTUALLY DROPPING OUT OF THE
REGULATED SYSTEM BECAUSE THEY.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE COST
ASSOCIATED TO ENGAGE IN ILLEGAL
MARKETPLACE.
SO WE MAY HAVE MISSED THAT THAT
PART OF HER TESTIMONY WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS EXCELLENT IN REGARDS
TO THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
REGULATORY BURDENS ON INDOOR AND
OUTDOOR AND I THINK THAT THAT.
AYE IT FRANKLY MY MY PITCH WAS
GOING TO BE REALLY NEED TO GET
GET EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND TRY
TO WORK IT OUT. UP BECAUSE THAT
IT MAKES IT STRONGER BUT I'M
CONVINCED THAT THERE REALLY ARE
DIFFERENT BURDENS ON ON.
THE OUTDOOR AS OPPOSED TO THE
INDOOR AND UP TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU'VE GOT THE INDUSTRY SAYING
LET'S DO TWO SEPARATE ONES UP I
I I DON'T HAVE ANY PROBLEM
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
GONNA BE FIVE WHICH YOU'RE GONNA
BE SIX WERE TO GOING TO BE
ADDING TO. THAT TO THE.
TO THE BELT WHEN IT GOES TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE AND WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING IT BACK IF
IF IT CHANGES SUBSTANTIALLY AND
WE DON'T LIKE WHAT IT WHAT IT
SAYS BECAUSE.
IT'S IT'S NOT WHAT WAS
ARTICULATED HERE BUT MISTER JOHN
SAWYER YOU YOU HAD A QUESTION.
.
PATRICK KIND OF COMMENTED AND
THAN I COULD HELP MR GREAT OF
TRYING TO FIND OUT HOW MANY
LEGAL AND ILLEGAL. I'M JUST GLAD
WE MAPS THAT PUBLIC CAN HELP YOU
LOOK AT.
CULTIVATED SANTIAGO ON THEIR
VERY EASILY SO AS AS ONE OF THE.
.
THE FOUNDING FIVE OF MISTER
BONTA.
A COOLEY LACKEY WOOD AND MYSELF
WERE THE ONES THAT ACTUALLY.
ALLOWS FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS AND
WANTS TO HELP WHICH SIXTY FOUR
PROSECUTE FOR DAN DID DON'T USE
WRITING OTHER. OF WE'VE BEEN
INVOLVED. IN IT FOR QUITE SOME
TIME. AND IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE ENTITIES GOING
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER HOW MADE IT
REALLY IMPORTANT MISTER GRAY
PROBABLY COULD ATTEST.
TWO WHEN YOU HAVE AN INDUSTRY
FIGHTING WITH ONE ANOTHER.
HOW WE CAN INHIBIT?
IT'S GROWTH OVER LONG PERIOD
TIME OBVIOUS INDUSTRIES THAT THE
INFANCY.
.
TO HAVE A.
IT THE HAVE THE FALLOUT AMONG
FAMILY EARLY ON IS NOT HEALTHY
IN IS NOT GOOD AND I. I WILL
LAST THE AUTHOR. ON IF YOU ALLOW
MYSELF IN IN ANY OF THE FOUND
THE FIVE TWO TO ASSIST THAT.
TRYING TO BRING US TOGETHER AND
MY SUGGESTION TO BOTH SIDES
INDOOR AN OUTSIDE.
THAT YOU COME TOGETHER AND
FIGURE IT OUT.
THE LAST THING YOU WANT IS FOR
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
LEGISLATORS TO FIGURE IT OUT FOR
YOU. YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LIKE
THAT THAT DAD NAM.
THAT'S SOLUTION I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR SENTENCES JONES SAWYER
AND AND WHEN WE. HAVE STRUCK
STRUCK THIS DEAL THIS COMPROMISE
IF YOU WILL YOU KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS
INDUSTRY IS REALLY GOING TO GO.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
IN ITS INFANCY THAT WE CAN HELP
THE. NON
YOU KNOW SIGN ABOUT WHO MAKES
THE BEST BROWNIES ARE ALSO
BESTOWING HERE IT'S JUST A HOW
DO WE MEET PROFESSIONAL
REGULATIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO TO
IN THIS CASE BE A FARMER. AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
SUCCESSFUL AND TODD AND
LEGITIMATE AND LEGAL.
AND
WHO KNOWS WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IN
A FEW YEARS IF THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MERGE THOSE
COMMISSIONS OR NOT. BUT I THINK
IT'S TOO SOON FOR US TO FIGURE
THAT OUT BUT. YOU KNOW EVEN FOR
US OLD TIMERS WE STILL WILL BE
AROUND.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S ALL I WOULD
SAVE COMMISSIONS ARE IMPORTANT
FOR IT NOW ILLEGITIMACY OF THIS
INDUSTRY. BUT FOR TRADING RULES
AND REGULATIONS AND STANDARDS
AND SO THAT ON EVERYBODY KNOW
WOOD LAYING THERE IN. AND MORE
IMPORTANT HOPEFULLY THEY CAN.
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER TO
RESOLVE.
EVEN CONFLICTS LIKE THIS ON THE
IRONY OF IT IS WHAT WE'RE HAVING
CONFLICTS ABOUT HOW TO CREATE A
INDUSTRY AT COMMITTEE COMMISSION
THAT COULD PULSE WE WILL. STOP A
LOT OF THIS SO MISUNDERSTANDING
AND SO I AM WILLING TO ROLL MY
SLEEVE UP ON TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR IF YOU ALLOW ME ON TO BE
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN IN THAT
DISCUSSION JUSTICE THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME. AND THE
OTHER FOUR FOUNDERS AND WE.
WE HAVE A. IS A LOT OF MEMBERS
WHO SAY WE HAVE A LOT OF
INFLUENCE ON HOW THINGS MOVE
FORWARD SO BE REAL IMPORTANT FOR
US TO BE INVOLVED. THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY.
BOB THANK GOD THE AUTHOR AND
MISTER JONES FOR.
DIRECTED ME TO THE CORRECT
INTERNET SITES TO.
ANSWER MY QUESTIONS.
BUT.
I GUESS I AYE STILL YOU KNOW I I
THINK DESCRIBING THE.
.
THE CANNABIS MARKETS IN TO SEIZE
THE CORRECT DESCRIPTION.
.
I SEE SOME.
TREMENDOUS HURDLES FRANKLY IN
FRONT OF THE INDUSTRY.
YOU KNOW IS THE CHAIR
GOVERNMENTAL RESEARCH COMMITTEE
IT WE'VE REGULATED ALCOHOL IN
THE STATE. SINCE PROHIBITION AND
THERE A LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED
THERE SOME SIMILARITIES
SOMETHINGS THAT ARE. A CLEARLY
DIFFERENT A BUT I THINK WE'RE
OFF TO A STUMBLING START. ALL
SAY THAT.
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH LICENSED
WHETHER WE KNOW THE NUMBER WE
DON'T KNOW THE NUMBER I THINK WE
CAN ALL COLLECTIVELY AGREE.
AND CERTAINLY THE INFORMATION
I'VE SEEN.
AND THE REPORTS WE'VE GOTTEN
ARE THAT THAT THEIR SOME REAL A
STUMBLING BLOCKS.
IN GETTING ENOUGH LICENSE
CULTIVATORS AND RETAILERS
ETCETERA.
GEOGRAPHICALLY DISPERSED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THERE'S NOT
A FUNCTIONAL MARKET AND IT JUST
STRIKES ME GIVE ME A LITTLE
PAUSE LITTLE PREMATURE TO BE
MOVING FORWARD.
WITH THIS KIND OF EFFORT.
ALTHOUGH I'M SURE AT SOME POINT
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE.
APPROPRIATE NECESSARY STEP
DISLIKE SHIRTS TODAY AND.
CAN ECHO MISTER SALSAS COMMENT
SUMS NOT SURE I'M COMFORTABLE
MOVE FORWARD TODAY.
CERTAINLY WE'LL SEE. I DON'T SEE
HOW IT GOES.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
YEAH.
I'M WORDS COMMENT I MEAN IT'S
KINDA INTERESTING SITTING HERE
AS SOMEONE WHO IS A FARMER AND
HAS BEEN PART OF A COMMISSION
THE RIGHTS COMMISSION. AND IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW THAT WORKS YOU
KNOW. A LOT OF THIS JUST DOESN'T
MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF SENSE TO ME
FIRST OF ALL.
WE MAY HAVE HAD SOME THE
COMMISSION'S CREATED FOR
GEOGRAPHIC PERSON PURPOSES BUT
THIS WILL BE THE FIRST ONE THAT
I'M AWARE OF THAT WE. MAKE A
BASED ON HOW THE PRODUCT IS
GROWN.
NOT AWARE OF ANYONE THAT THAT
SPLITS ABOUT.
THAT WAY AND AS YOU COME INTO
THE THE LEGAL MARKETPLACE THANK
YOU BY THE WAY FOR COMING INTO
THE THAT THE LEGAL MARKET GREAT
NOT LEGAL MARKETPLACE. IS A
COUPLE THINGS THAT YOU'RE GONNA
GET INTRODUCED TO ONE AS
COMPETITION.
YEAH YOU ARE GONNA HAVE TO
COMPETE WITH PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW
AND AND BASICALLY. IT IN A
MARKETPLACE AND MAKE HIM MAKE
YOUR PRODUCT YOU KNOW.
.
IN A WAY THAT IS EFFICIENT AND
THAT AND THAT YOU CAN GET A GOOD
VALUE FOR YOUR PRODUCT. YOU KNOW
SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING HEY OURS
ARE GROWN IN THIS CERTAIN WAY.
AB NOT ORGANIC GROWERS ARE DOING
THAT RIGHT NOW. WE DON'T
SEPARATE OUT THEIR COMMISSIONS.
BUT THEY MARKET THEMSELVES AS
ORGANIC THEY'RE ABLE TO GET
BETTER VALUE FOR THEIR PRODUCT.
EVEN THOUGH.
THE COSTS MAY BE DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO GET
MORE VALUE FOR THEIR PRODUCT
THEY CAN COMPETE COMPETE IN THE
MARKETPLACE SO. THAT'S DIFFERENT
FROM SAYING UP A COMMISSION.
YES THERE'S ALSO REGULATION
WELCOME THE DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA IN A LEGAL WAY.
THOSE OF US IN FARMING.
HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR YEARS
AND AS WE JUST HEARD ABOUT THE.
YOU KNOW YES THERE'S A LOT OF
GREAT PRODUCTS GOING TO
CALIFORNIA IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
DOING GREAT THINGS NARROW
BECAUSE WE HAVE A STRONG.
AGRICULTURE SECTOR BUT IT'S.
ITS FUTURE IS DEFINITELY NOT
CERTAIN BECAUSE OF THE
REGULATORY CLIMATE.
IN THE STATE THE MORE THAT WE
KEEP HAVING YOU KNOW THESE
BARRIERS AS YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
LOSING PEOPLE NOT EVIL ABLE TO
FARM. WELCOME TO BE IN A FARMER
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S BUT AGAIN THAT DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH THE
COMMISSION AND THEN A COMMISSION
IS FORMED.
LARGELY TO FOR THE GROWERS TO
BAN TOGETHER AND PROMOTE THEIR
PRODUCTS
PROMOTE AND MARKET AND MARKET.
THEIR PRODUCTS YES THERE'S ALSO
YOU KNOW TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO.
WORK THE REGULATORY BARRIERS ONE
THAT I CAN THINK OF AND RICE
WOULD BE THE.
.
IRRIGATED LANDS PROGRAM AND
KINDA COMING INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH THAT.
BUT LARGELY IT'S ABOUT
MARKETING AND SO. LET'S TAKE A
LITTLE STEP BACK.
THIS ISN'T AN AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCT.
IN THE NORMAL WAY THAT WE'VE
SEEN THIS ISN'T LIKE DRIED PLUMS
AND MORE AND WALNUTS AND RICE.
WE'RE STILL DO WHAT THE SCHEDULE
ONE DRUG.
LARGELY THIS IS THE END USE OF
THIS PRODUCT IS TO BE SMOKED.
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S ALSO
EDIBLES AND AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE AS WELL BUT LARGE THAT'S
WHAT IT IS. AND I WOULD JUST ASK
THIS BODY LIKE.
WHAT WOULD WE DON'T GROW TOBACCO
IN CALIFORNIA?
BUT IF WE DID WOULD YOU BE OKAY
WITH THE A PROMOTIONAL.
COMMISSION FOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
THE A WE'RE GONNA BAND TOGETHER
AND PROMOTE THE USE OF OF
TOBACCO I DON'T SEE TOO MUCH OF
A DIFFERENCE.
WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN
NOT AND AND TO ME THAT'S NOT THE
APPROPRIATE.
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR THIS THERE
ARE HEALTH THERE ARE HEALTH
ANOTHER.
ISSUES ASSOCIATE WITH MARIJUANA
ALL WE'VE DONE IN CALIFORNIA'S
IT MADE IT LEGAL. FOR ADULTS.
TO RECREATIONALLY USES.
WE HAVEN'T NECESSARILY MADE THIS
INTO AN AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY.
AND THEY TREATED IT THE SAME WAY
AS AN AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY AND
I HONESTLY DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD.
SOLIDUS BACCHUS UP AND SAY IS
THIS REALLY THE APPROPRIATE
THING TO BE CREATING A MARKET OR
MARKETING PROMOTIONAL.
COMMISSION.
FOR CALIFORNIA GROWN AND I'LL
I'LL GIVE THE AUTHORS VERY
CLEVERLY NAMED COMMISSION.
SON GROWN YOU KNOW.
MAKES IT SOUND LIKE GOMEZ IS
LIKE A RAISINS OR SOMETHING
RIGHT YEAH.
.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS I DON'T
KNOW THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE FOR A COMMISSION.
TO BE FORMED.
.
AND SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
IMPLICATIONS TO THAT. THAT WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THIS A LITTLE
BIT PREMATURE THIS INDUSTRY
HASN'T REALLY GOTTEN OUT THERE.
I MEAN IT'S VERY MUCH IN ITS
INFANCY THERE'S LOT OF THINGS WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT SO TO CREATE A
COMMISSION.
AND THEN ALSO DID NOT ONLY THAT
LET'S CREATE TWO COMMISSIONS.
AND SPLIT THOSE UP IN A WAY WE
NEVER HAVE BEFORE WHY SHOULD WE
DO THAT.
WHY SHOULD WE TREAT THIS SO MUCH
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE'VE TREATED
AS ANYTHING ELSE?
AND SO YEAH I WOULD JUST SAY AT
AND I THINK IT'S NOT READY THIS
ISN'T FULLY COOKED.
YOU KNOW SO MAYBE WE MAYBE WE
SHOULD THE.
YEAH I THINK I THINK TAKE A
PAUSE ON THIS AYE I AM I WILL BE
VOTING NO TODAY AND BUT I THINK
THIS IS A LOT MORE TIME BEFORE
WE JUST MOVE FOR SOME
COMMISSION.
THAT OBVIOUSLY STILL HAS A LOT
OF ISSUES EVEN AMONGST ITS OWN.
INDUSTRY A HAS A LOT OF ISSUES I
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE THIS DOWN TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I GUESS I LOOK AT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY NAM.
THE VOTERS HAVE DECIDED THIS IS
A LEGAL POT PRODUCT AND I LOOK
AT IT VERY MUCH LIKE.
WINE GRAPES IN.
IT YOU DON'T YOU CAN YOU TURN IT
INTO SOME SOMETHING THAT IF YOU
OVER INDULGE.
IT'S
YOU'RE IN TROUBLE.
AND.
SO IN MANY WAYS TO FOR ME LET
ME JUST TELL YOU THAT THAT MY
PITCH WAS GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
YOU REALLY NEED TO GET.
BOTH INDOOR OUTDOOR TOGETHER
WORK TOGETHER AND AND SEE IF
THERE'S LIKE A COMPROMISE.
I SEE THAT THERE IS A
COMPROMISE COMPROMISES THEY
WANNA BE SEPARATE AND MAYBE AT
SOME POINT THEY DO WORK TOGETHER
AND IT BECOMES ONE COMMISSION
BUT.
.
YOU KNOW WHENEVER IT BUSINESS
COMES FORWARD TO ME ESPECIALLY
IN THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY AND
SAYS LOOK WE WANT IS WE WANT TO
CREATE A BOARD.
ARE A COMMISSION AND WERE
WILLING TO IT CHARGE OURSELVES.
SO THAT WE CAN THEN GET
INFORMATION DISSEMINATED AMONG
OUR MEMBERS I HATE THAT I REALLY
DON'T GET INVOLVED IN SAYING NO
I I JUST DON'T THINK THAT. YOU
DESERVE TO HAVE YOUR OWN BOARD
AYE IT WE GET TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE'VE. BLAST AGRICULTURAL BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS.
IF IF THEY COME FORWARD I KIND
OF FEEL LIKE.
THERE'S A THERE'S A PURPOSE AND
THERE'S A REASON AND.
FOR ME THIS IS.
A SITUATION WHERE IT IT IS A IT
IS A. IN IS IN ITS INFANCY. AND
UP THERE IS A LOT TO LEARN AND A
LOT TO KNOW IN ORDER TO STAY
WITHIN THAT. THE LANES THAT THE
STATE HAS SET UP IN ORDER FOR
THIS.
A INDUSTRY MOVE FORWARD AND
THERE ARE A LOT THERE ARE A LOT
OF REGULATIONS AND THERE'S A LOT
OF REGULATIONS BECAUSE BECAUSE
JUST LIKE ALCOHOL IT'S TREATED
DIFFERENTLY THAN OTHER
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS.
ANYTHING THAT IS. THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO.
.
TO GET YOU. DRUNK HIGH OR.
IMPAIRED IN A WAY THAT AFFECTS
OTHER PEOPLE THERE'S REGULATION.
AND SO I SEE THIS RIGHT RIGHT
ALONG THE LINE WITH WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE AND SO I I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO HAVING IT GO FORWARD
IN AND HAVING IT BE TWO SEPARATE
COMMISSIONS. ON IF IN IN THAT
PROCESS IT IT'S DECIDED THAT ONE
WOULD BE BETTER I'M OKAY WITH
THAT TOO BUT.
BUT I'M WE THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
I FALL ON IT TODAY AND I IF IF
YOU'RE GOING STE SO THE WAY THAT
THE PROCESS WORKS HERE AT THAT
AT.
.
AT OUR LEVEL IS IT IS THAT
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
ADDING.
ANOTHER COMMISSION AND THAT'S.
WE DON'T ALLOW AMENDMENTS AT.
APPEAR BECAUSE IT IT'S.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT'S DONE UP
BUT YOU HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE
HEARING OTHERWISE I WOULDA SAID
LET'S PUT THIS OVER TO THE
TWENTY FIFTH AND WE CAN COME
BACK AND YOU CAN SHOW US THAT
AMENDED LANGUAGE.
IF YOU.
.
IF YOU SAY THIS IS WHAT I'M
GONNA DO A WEEK EXPECT TO SEE
THE BILL CHANGE THAT WAY AND I'M
I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
AS A COMMITTEE CHAIR AND AS I
SAID WE ALWAYS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO BRING IT BACK AND AND TO TAKE
A LOOK AT IT AGAIN IF IT. ENDS
UP SUBSTANTIALLY DIFFERENT I
DON'T THINK THAT YOU WOULD DO
THAT.
BUT I'M NOT SURE YOU EAT
THERE'S THAT THERE'S ENOUGH OF
SUPPORT HERE SO I THINK WE NEED
TO FINISH KIND FINISHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. AND.
I THINK I WAS ASKING FOR
QUESTIONS PEOPLE HAVE MADE THEIR
COMMENTS ALL I CHIU A CONCLUDE
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T LET GIVE YOU
THE FINAL SAY.
DEBT MEMBERS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTARY AND OF COURSE.
.
YOU DID THE COMMITMENT IS IS THE
ONE THAT I MADE THAT WE WOULD
TAKE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE OF
COURSE WE'D BE ABLE TO COME BACK
IF THERE IS ANY. DISCREPANCY AND
WHAT WAS UNDERSTOOD BY YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE.
THE CHOICE WE HAVE BEFORE US IS.
TAKE YOU KNOW STRUCK THIS
COMPROMISE AYE AND SUPPORT WHAT
WE TALK ABOUT AS A NASCENT
INDUSTRY OR IN INDUSTRY IN ITS
INFANCY BUT.
LET'S REMEMBER THAT THIS IN
FACT.
IS NOT A CRAWLING BABY.
THIS IS NOT AN INDUSTRY IN
INFANCY THIS IS OF OUR A A
MARKET THAT HAS BEEN.
OPERATING.
.
YOU KNOW.
IN AN UNREGULATED I AND ILLEGAL
FASHION FOR DECADES IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS A BIG INDUSTRY.
HUGE IMPACT ON OUR STATE HUGE
IMPACT ON OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND VOTERS HAVE DECIDED THAT WE
WANT TO REGULATE IT THAT IT WILL
BE LEGAL. AND WE HAVE AN OPTION
HERE WE HAVE A GROWERS WHO WANT
TO WORK TOGETHER TO PROFESSIONAL
EYES.
AND LEGITIMIZING LEGALIZE THEIR
OPERATIONS TO THE STANDARDS THAT
WE HAVE SAT.
OR.
HAVE THEM UNABLE TO DO THAT AND
PERHAPS CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN A
WAY THAT HAS HAD NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES.
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT I OR
OTHERWISE.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A AN EASY
CHOICE TO MAKE.
WE WE WANT TO GO AHEAD WITH THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS AND ALLOW
THEM.
PROFESSIONAL LIES AND LEGALIZE
AND AND RUN AS PROFESSIONAL
OPERATIONS AND ALSO RECOGNIZE
THE VERY DIFFERENT REGULATIONS
THAT ARE GROWERS FOLLOW AND
RESPECT THAT. I ENHANCE THE
COMPROMISE THAT WAS STRUCK BY
ALL OF THE GROWERS THAT WERE
REPRESENTED TODAY THANK YOU
ASKED WHEN I GO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TO GALLAGHER
TO PUT TWO QUICK QUESTIONS TO
LOUIE BECAUSE I KNOW HE'S YOU
KNOW HAS THE EXPERTISE IN THIS I
MEAN.
ARE THESE PRIVATE COMMISSIONS
ARE PRIMARILY FORMED FOR
MARKETING AND PROMOTION OF THE
PRODUCT
IT THAT'S MY ANDERSON AND ISN'T
THAT WHAT AND I GUESS THE SECOND
QUESTION ISN'T THAT WHAT.
THIS COMMISSION WOULD DO IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT
PROFESSIONALIZATION REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE I MEAN.
IN THIS LEGISLATION DOESN'T THIS
ALSO PERMIT THE PROMOTION AND
MARKETING.
OF THAT PRODUCT.
AND CHAIR OF YOU MAKE ME PRETTY.
A.
SO.
THESE THESE ENTITIES THESE
BOARDS THESE COMMISSIONS WERE
CREATED OR AUTHORIZED UNDER THE
NIGHT THE MARKING ACT OF
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN.
AND WITHOUT A DOUBT
HUB.
IN THOSE DAYS IN AND AS RECENTLY
IS YOU KNOW THIRTY FORTY YEARS
AGO WHEN WE STARTED TRADING
COMMISSIONS FOR AGRICULTURAL
CLIENTS IT WAS ABOUT MARKETING.
BUT THAT'S CHANGED.
AND YOU'LL HEAR MORE THAN ONE
COMMISSION C. E. O. THESE DAYS
SAY WERE NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
ASKING CONSUMERS THE MORE OF OUR
STUFF.
THAT'S BEING DONE.
IT'S BEING DONE ON A ON A
GLOBAL SCALE IT'S BEING DONE BY
NATIONAL CHECKOFF PROGRAMS IT'S
BEING DONE IN IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
MORE PROGRAMS TODAY.
LAST YEAR THE SEE THE SPINY
LOBSTER COMMISSION WAS CREATED
NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE OUT
MARKETING SPINY LOBSTERS BECAUSE
THAT INDUSTRY FOUND A NEED TO
COME TOGETHER AND UNIFIED TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES.
SO.
YES THERE IS LANGUAGE IN HERE
BOILERPLATE LANGUAGE LIKE YOU
SEE IN MOST COMMISSIONS DEALING
WITH THE PROMOTION OF THE
PRODUCT.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT MOST
COMMISSIONS TODAY HAVE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM THE
MARKETING ANY MORE STUFF.
TWO LET'S DO RESEARCH.
LET'S DO BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES LET'S OVERSEE
REGULATORY PROGRAMS YOU MENTION
THE RICE PROGRAM YOUR DATA LANCE
PROGRAM IS NOT THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT THE RICE OVERSEAS IT ALSO.
HAS A A PESTICIDE CALLED THE
QUALITY ASSURANCE PROGRAM A
WATER QUALITY ASSURANCE PROGRAMS
AND WE START TO SEE BECAUSE.
THESE PROGRAMS CAN. CAN OVERSEE
AN ENTIRE INDUSTRY THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT REGULATORY
AUTHORITY IN REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT SO.
I BELIEVE THAT.
THE COULD THIS COMMISSION.
WHILE IT HAS THAT LANGUAGE IN
THEIR THE BOILERPLATE LANGUAGE
IT YOU SEE.
THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF A SON
GROWN CANNABIS COMMISSION OR
EVEN AN INDOOR CANCER CAMPUS
COMMISSION IS NOT GOING TO BE
ABOUT THE MARKETING.
I THINK THERE'S VENTURE
CAPITALIST ALL OVER THE STATE
THAT ARE GONNA MARKET CANNABIS
THE WAY THEY WANT AND THAT'S
WHAT THE DISPENSARIES DO.
WHEN I WAS FIRST APPROACH IN OUR
FIRM WAS FIRST APPROACHED AND
AND.
HELD MEETINGS IN THE EMERALD
TRIANGLE ON THIS WHAT WE HEARD
WAS WE NEED A VEHICLE TO HELP US
SUSTAIN.
WE NEED A VEHICLE TO TO WALK US
THROUGH AND GUIDE US THROUGH THE
REGULATORY A PROCESS THESE THAT
WE'RE NOW DEALING WITH WE NEED
RESEARCH WE NEED BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES WE NEED A COHESIVE
VOICE SO THAT WE CAN DO THAT SO.
I COMMISSION THE BEAUTIFUL THING
ABOUT IT IS WHEN A GROUP OF
PRODUCERS COME TO YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE COMMISSION CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY LIKE WHATEVER BEST
FITS THEIR NEEDS. WE'VE SEEN
THAT THERE'S THE CALIFORNIA
NAVEL ORANGE COMMISSION CREATED
SPECIFICALLY FOR NAVEL ORANGES
NOT CITRUS NAVEL ORANGES THERE'S
THE CALIFORNIA ICEBERG LETTUCE
COMMISSION. NOT FOR ALL LET US
JUST FOR ICEBERGS
YOU GOT THE TABLE GREAT
COMMISSION ON ONE SIDE AND THE
WINE GRAPE COMMISSION ON THE
OTHER. SO AGAIN.
WHAT STATE LAW HAS PROVIDED THEM
WITH THE MARKETING ACTINIDE TEAM
THIRTY SEVEN PROVIDES IS THIS
OPPORTUNITY? FOR PRODUCERS TO
COME TOGETHER SAY WE WANT TO
ASSESS OURSELVES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CREATING A
COLLECTIVE VOICE.
AND.
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS
COMMISSION IS DOING.
THE NEXT COMMISSION THAT WE'RE
GONNA RIGHT INTO THIS BILL WILL
DO AND THAT'S KIND OF FOLLOW IN
THE TRADITION OF THESE THESE
LAWS OVER THE LAST FORTY PLUS
YEARS.
WELL IF I COULD JUST RESPOND AND
I APPRECIATE THAT THAT LOUIS OF
THE RESPECTFULLY AT THINK THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT DISINGENUOUS
BECAUSE YES SIR YES THERE ARE
REGULATORY COMPONENTS THIS AND
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AND
PROGRAM.
BUT PRIMARILY THEY ARE PROMOTING
I CAN. WE DRIVE EACH YOU DRIVE
INTO THE SACRAMENTO ON ON THE
RADIO IS PLAYING.
A CALIFORNIA RICE COMMERCIAL ON
ARMSTRONG THE GETTY WRITE Y. TO
PROMOTE CALIFORNIA RICE IN WHAT
IS DOING AND TO AND TO PROMOTE
PROMOTE THAT INDUSTRY.
SO THAT THAT THE QUESTION HERE
BEFORE IS THAT IS THAT WE WANT
FOR THE MARIJUANA INDUSTRY DO
YOU WANT TO PROMOTE THIS PRODUCT
YOU BROUGHT UP ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT COMMISSIONS. THOSE ARE
ALL SEPARATE COMMODITIES
THEY ARE SEPARATE COMMODITIES.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TABLE GRAPES AND WINE GRAPES AS
IT IS THERE'S THEY ARE DIFFERENT
COMMODITIES THAT ARE BEING
PROMOTED SO AGAIN. THAT DOES
THAT'S NOT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME EXACTPRODUCT WE'RE GOING
TO CREATE TWO DIFFERENT YEAH
BECAUSE IT CALDERON I THINK I
THINK MISTER BROWN WILL OFTEN
DETERMINE THEY DO CAN ATTEMPTING
TO ANSWER YOU ARE FINISHED
MISTER LEVINE AND THEN YOU CAN
RESPOND. FILTERED I JUST GOT
WHERE I JUST POINT OUT IS THE
FACT THOSE ARE DIFFERENT
COMMODITIES
MAYBE I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT WE
KNOW. TALK HERE THAT UNDERSTANDS
THAT DIFFERENCE
IN AGRICULTURE BUT THAT'S THE
TRUTH THEY ARE DIFFERENT
COMMODITIES IN THEIR PROMOTING
THAT PRODUCT.
THAT THAT COME INTO THE QUESTION
FOR THIS BODY IS IS THAT THE
SAME THING THAT WE WANT TO DO
HERE WHAT WE PROMOTE TOBACCO IF
IT WAS GOING TO CALIFORNIA. WE
PROMOTE THAT PRODUCT IN THEIR
CULTURAL PRODUCT SO SO WHAT
WE'VE HEARD POINT THAT YOU'VE
MADE IT BACK IN MY HEAD WERE
WHERE WHERE WERE GOING. A LITTLE
BIT OFF SO I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT THE DIALOGUE WILL EVERYBODY
WILL GO GET A BEER TONIGHT WON'T
FINISH SHOT THAT DISCUSSION BUT
NOW WE HAVE THE BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE TO DO
AND WE'VE SPENT ALMOST AN HOUR
ON THIS ONE WITH THAT A LOT
MORE.
TO GO SO I MISS EGGMAN JUDGES
RULED BROUGHT WITH IT AND I WAS
RAISING MY HIM FOR A OF ONE OF
THE FOUNDING FATHERS. JUMPED
AND.
.
IT'S BECAUSE BY IS MICHAEL.
MY QUESTION WAS GOING TO BE JUST
AROUND AND AGAIN I ALSO LOOKED
THE PORTALS WHAT WE'VE BEEN WHAT
WE'VE BEEN SITTING HERE BUT DO
WE KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHICH ARE MY TWO
COMMISSIONS NOW NOT JUST THE
NUMBER ALONG WITH TO. AND IT TWO
SEPARATE THAT'S WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
AND THEN IS THERE A IS THERE A
MARKET SHARE OF THE SUN GROWN
VERSES.
IN HOPE IN IN YOU KNOW NOT NOT
SOME GROWN. UP AND. AND IS
THERE.
THAT.
AND AND THEM AND THEN MORE TALK
MUCH SUSTAINABILITY.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT WATER AND
AND I KNOW ACTUAL FARMERS ARE
MEAN. SON SOME FARMERS HAVE TO
DO ABOVE WATCH SUITABILITY PLAN
EVERYTHING AND I DON'T THINK.
HYDROPONIC FARMERS ARE HELD TO
THAT SAME STANDARD BECAUSE IT
NOT ON ON THE GROUND WATER AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
BUT.
BUT OUR IS YOU CAN BE SOME
ATTENTION PAID TO THE MARKET
SHARE IT IS IT EQUAL NOW WILL
THE GOAL BEFORE TIP TO REMAIN
EQUAL AND IS THERE ANY.
YEAH.
YES YOU MAKE.
AND TO THE QUESTION I THINK AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON FED
HAVE. SO I'M CURRENTLY MARKET
SHARE IS GREAT TENNIS SKEWED ON
BOTH SIDES RATE SO IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT A FLOWER MARKET FOR
INHALABLE. ON CONSUMPTION THE
MARKET SHARE IS ROUGHLY EIGHTY
PLUS PERCENT INDOOR IN THE
MARKETPLACE VERSES ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT OR SO FOR A SON GROWN IN
THE MARKETPLACE.
HOWEVER WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
INTO SAY MANUFACTURED PRODUCTS.
A LOT OF THOSE MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS ARE BEING.
PRODUCED USING SON GROWN
PRODUCTS ON LARGELY BECAUSE WE.
WELL SOME GRIM PRODUCTS TEND TO
TESS CLEANER WE HAVE LESS
PESTICIDE USE BECAUSE WHERE I'M
A LITTLE MORE BALANCED WITH BUT
OFFICIALS IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
ANYTHING THERE IS A SECOND PART
TO YOUR QUESTION MY APOLOGY I
WILL USE MARKET SHARE WILL THERE
BE ANY LIKE THAT ATTEMPT OR
TRACKING TO SEE OF THAT BALLOT
STAYS IN. IF IT STAYS IN THE
SAME ROOM THAT IS THAT ANY KIND
OF GOAL. I MEAN I THINK IT WOULD
BE FABULOUS AND ONCE IN A
COMMISSION IS A STYLISH TO
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER
THE REPORTS THAT SHOW WHAT WAS
PRODUCED BY REGION AND WHAT THAT
LOOKED LIKE IN THE MARKETPLACE
HOA WAS UTILIZED. I THINK WERE A
WAYS DOWN THE ROAD FROM THAT.
SUNBURN FARMERS OF COURSE WOULD
LOVE TO SEE A BALANCE IN THE
MARKETPLACE IN THE MARKET SHARE
BUT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
CALIFORNIA.
UNDER THE FOUNDING FATHERS HERE
AS WELL AS.
MERCER HOUSE VERY RIGOROUS AND
RIGID.
REGULATIONS AROUND ADVERTISING
SO WHERE BASICALLY BOUNDED BY
PRETTY LIMITED ADVERTISING
OPPORTUNITIES.
OKAY. A AND APPRECIATE THAT AND
ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE FOUNDING
FATHERS XIN. MANSE PLAINNESS UP
AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE WE
MARKET LINE A LOT AND IT'S A
SIMCHA QUANTITY.
SO ON THAT CONCLUDES THAT THE
HEARING PART OF IT I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION IF SOMEONE IS
WILLING TO MAKE THE MOTION.
FOUNDING FIVE I MAKE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED.
THE ROLE PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMEY ARE OUT BY
OF THE ORAL AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING ADHERE CURRY
FLORA.
FLORA AYE GALLAGHER.
THOSE.
NO GRAY.
RAINY.
CAN I TAKE A.
NOT VOTING.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE A LEVINE AYE
LEVINE AYE SALAS.
STATE. NOT VOTING.
WE NEED ONE. THAT WE NEED ONE
VOTE UP WITH THIS WILL REMAIN
OPEN AND FOR THAT ABSENT MEMBERS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE VOTES WELL.
THANKS VERY MUCH I'M SURE
MEMBERS THINK YOU AT BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO YOUR SECOND GO I'D
LIKE TO.
IDENTIFY ITEM NUMBER ONE. AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR A GONZALEZ
FLETCHER BELL AGRICULTURAL
PASSED
SHOT HOLE BORDER BEATLES AND
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWO TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON INVASIVE SPECIES AS PART
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR WITH IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. MOTION'S
BEEN MADE AND SECONDED.
THE ROLE PLACE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR COMEY ROI COMEY ALL AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS I A YEAR CURRY FLORA.
LARA AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAY.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE JONES SAWYER.
LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN THINKERS OUT ITS
ENCOUNTERS OUT WELL WE JUST GOT
THROUGH HALF OF OUR AGENDA THAT
WAS GOOD. COULD TWO SECONDS.
WILL MOVE ON TO MISTER LEVINE
SECOND BILL WHICH IS AB THIRTY
TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO BEGIN MY
PRESENTATION.
ON AB THIRTY TWENTY ONE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY JOINT AUTHORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLACE AND SOME
MEMBER MEDINA WHO. I THINK
WITHOUT THEIR PARTNERSHIP.
THIS BILL WOULD BE A MUCH
WEAKER ONE THAT WOULD NOT
REPRESENT TAP THE ABLE TO
REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA AND DIE
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO PARTNER
WITH DOWN. TO MAKE SURE THIS
BILL GETS ACROSS THAT THE FINISH
LINE OR AT LEAST GETS TO HEAR
AYE DEPENDING ON THE QUESTIONS
THAT MR GALLAGHER MAY HAVE.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN I OF FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A. B.
THIRTY TWENTY ONE WHICH REQUIRES
KEACH FREE HAND HOUSING. FOR ALL
EGG LAYING HENS RAISED OR HIS
EGGS ARE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. AND ANIMAL
WELFARE ADVOCATES ARE DEMANDING
CAGE FREE PRODUCTION FOR EGGS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE
NATION MOST NEW AT PRODUCTION
THAT IS BEING BUILT IS EITHER
CAGE FREE. OR ABLE TO BE
CONVERTED CAGE FREE WITH LITTLE
ADDITIONAL EFFORT OR COSTS
TEN MILES THAT IMPACTS ON
MARKETS AND CONSUMERS THIS BILL
INCORPORATES A STEP REQUIRING
EACH TEND TO HAVE. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR SQUIRREL SQUARE
INCHES IN TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN
THE CONVERSION TO CAGE FREE BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THIS ALLOWS
THE HANDS TO BE REYES WITH MORE
SPACE. AND THE CONVERSIONS THAT
REQUIRE TIME AND PERMITS TO COME
IN OVER THE PHASE IN PERIOD. THE
BILL INCORPORATES NATIONAL CAGE
FREE STANDARDS IN THE CALIFORNIA
LAW AND SAGER'S THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HAND
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS TO MINIMIZE
IMPACTS ON CONSUMERS. AND THE
NATIONWIDE INDUSTRY.
THE LEGISLATION RETAINS
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
ANIMAL WELFARE AND MEETS
EXPECTATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS THAT THEY ARE
PURCHASING EGGS RAISED CAGE
FREE.
AND TO THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
ANIMAL CARE FRESHNESS AND FOOD
SAFETY. WITH ME TODAY IS DENNIS
ALBION WHO REPRESENTS SEVERAL
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU LIKE THAT.
DOUG TURNED OVER A MOMENTARILY
TO STEVE GAP EARLY WHO IS A
FARMER HERE IN THE CENTRAL AND
EGG FARMER IN CENTRAL VALLEY.
FOR SOME COMMENTS ON THE THE
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEVEN
CAREFULLY PRESIDENT OF DON'T
BELIEVE FAMILY FARMS.
MY COMPANY FARMS BOTH ALMONDS
AND EGGS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE PRODUCE NUMEROUS VARIETIES OF
AIDS INCLUDING ORGANIC EGGS AND
RICH DAY EXAM QE TREE EGGS.
I AM CURRENTLY THE PRESIDENT OF
A STAFF THAT IS THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA EGG FARMERS.
A STAFF DOES NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BILL.
BUT WE WERE REQUESTED BY THE
AUTHOR TO ATTEND TO PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT ON THE MEASURE.
AS MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS
MANY OF THE KEY RETAILERS
GROCERS AND FOOD SERVICE
ENTITIES ARE CONVERTING TO
STARVING OR SELLING ONLY CAGE
FREE EGGS.
IN FACT
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE ENTITIES THAT
SELL EGGS ARE EIGHT PRODUCTS
HAVE COMMITTED TO CONVERT TO
CAGE FREE EGGS ONLY.
ADDITIONALLY STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT HANDS WITH LESS STRESS AND
MORE LIVING SPACE ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE CARRIERS OF
SALMONELLA.
MANY EGG FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
CURRENTLY CONVERTING ALL OR A
PORTION OF THEIR OPERATIONS TO
CAGE FREE. IN ORDER TO SERVE
THIS DEMAND AND ARE PROVIDING
MORE LIVING SPACE FOR ANIMAL
WELFARE AND FOOD SAFETY
PURPOSES.
IN FACT MY FAMILY FARM HAS
COMMITTED TO BE QUE TREE BY THE
END OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE.
THE BILL REFERENCES AN INDUSTRY
STANDARD OF THE U. EP TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CAGE FREE
STANDARDS.
THIS WILL HELP ALL THE NATION'S
AID FARMERS MEET A DEFINED QUE
TREE REQUIREMENT. CONSISTENT
WITH MOST OF THE NATION'S CAGE
FREE MARKETS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES NEARLY SIX
YEARS UNTIL ALL FARMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE IN THE
NATION THAT SERVE CALIFORNIA.
WILL NEED TO MEET QUE TREE
STANDARDS.
THIS TIME IS NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THE NATION'S AID FARMERS
TIME TO GET PERMITS.
LAND YOU USE APPROVAL. OBTAIN
CAPITAL AND FILLED OUT BROODING
AND LAYING FACILITIES.
THIS CONVERSION WILL BE A
MONUMENTAL TASK IN IS ESTIMATED
COST THE INDUSTRY APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
TO MEET THE STANDARD FOR ALL
SALES IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION THIS TIMELINE IS
CONSISTENT WITH MOST OF THE
ENTITIES THAT HAVE COMMITTED TO
A CONVERSION TO USING OR SELLING
ONLY CAGE FREE EGGS.
HOWEVER TO ENCOURAGE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES A STEP UP IN ENCLOSURE
SIZE PROVIDING ALL HANDS AT
LEAST ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
SQUARE INCHES. REGARDLESS OF
HOUSING SYSTEM BY THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY.
THIS ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
CRITICS BY REQUIRING THE HUNDRED
FOURTY FOUR INCH SPACE
REQUIREMENT PER BIRD IN JUST TWO
YEARS. THAT'S PROVIDING EACH HEN
WITH NEARLY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
MORE SPACE THAN THE CURRENT
PROPOSITION TWO SPACE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND MORE THAN DOUBLE THE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS FOR.
VERSES NONCOMPLIANT QUE JADE'S.
THE BILL IS NARROWLY CRAFTED
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE PROPER
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR COMPLIANCE
FOR THE NATION'S AEG FARMERS.
AND WILL INTEGRATE INTO
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING FOOD
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM WHICH
IS FUNDED THROUGH AN INDUSTRY
ASSESSMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
DENNIS ALBION AND YOU HAVE A
CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED ON THE
PACIFIC COAST RENDERING
ASSOCIATION. GRAIN TO FEED
PROVIDES LIVESTOCK NUTRIENTS
GRAIN AND MICRONUTRIENTS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LIVESTOCK
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING THE
POULTRY.
INDUSTRY ALSO THE HORSE AND PET
FOOD.
WELL. RENDERING PROVIDES
ESSENTIAL SERVICES THE DEAL WITH
ANIMALS AND POULTRY CARCASSES.
BOTH THE STROKES ASSOCIATION
STRIVE FOR A STRONG LIVESTOCK
INDUSTRY AND TO ASSIST AND
PROVIDE A SAFE WHOLESOME OUR
PRODUCT.
WE SUPPORT THREE THIRTY TWENTY
ONE IS IT IS TAILORED TO ADDRESS
INDUSTRY TRENDS CONSUMER DEMANDS
AND FOOD SAFETY.
I CALAVERAS CONSUMERS ARE
INCREASINGLY DEMANDING CAGE FREE
A. AND THE AND SO OUR RETAIL
PARTNERS.
NATIONAL CAGE FREE STANDARDS ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL SO THAT
AGAIN EVERYBODY KNOWS THE RULES.
THERE IDENTIFIED AND ITS
NATIONWIDE AND COMPLIANT WITH
THE EXISTING INDUSTRY STANDARDS.
THERE'S A SIX YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION THE SUPERVISOR AS
MR GET BELIEVE DISCUSSED THE
REQUIREMENT TO MEET OUR TO BUILD
OUT. TO
GET PERMITS TO GET CAPITAL TO.
PAY FOR THESE CONVERSIONS AND
FRANKLY OF IT ACTUALLY. EVERY
HAND DOES NOT LAY AN EGG UNTIL
SHE'S.
BUT AT LEAST SIX MONTHS OLD SO
YOU ON HANDS ON JANUARY FIRST OF
THE YEAR. YOU BETTER HAVE THEM
BORN AND IN THEIR IN PLACE BY
BASICALLY JUNE THIRTIETH OR. YOU
KNOW THEY'RE DOING THEIR CYCLE.
THAT THE BILL AS YOU DISCUSSED
ALSO PROVIDES A STEP UP WITH THE
THE THE SIZE REQUIREMENTS AND
THEN. YOU BUILD TO THE TO THE
CAGE REQUIREMENT A CLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS A CAGE FREE
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT WAY THERE'S
A STEP UP THAT'LL EASE THE
CONSUMER.
SITUATION AND ALSO ALLOW FOR.
MORE SMOOTH TRANSITION.
TODAY WE MIGHT HEAR FROM SOME
OPPONENTS AND KIND OF FORCE
VERSURI. WE MAY DISCUSS THAT
THERE'S BEEN AN INITIATIVE THAT
HAVE BEEN FILED.
.
THE.
THE IN THIS BILL DEALS WITH EGGS
THAT INITIATIVE IS FAR BROADER.
AND I DON'T THINK ANYTHING.
WOULD STOP
THE FOLKS FROM GETTING A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SENATOR
LEGISLATOR TO INTRODUCE A BILL
TO COVER THE OTHER INDUSTRIES
THAT'S THEIR CHOICE WE JUST
FOCUSED ON. A MAJOR CALIFORNIA
COMMODITY THAT'S ALSO A MAJOR
NATIONWIDE COMMODITY.
AND THEN UP FINALLY THIS WOULD
BE.
TIED TO BE ENFORCEMENT THE
ENFORCEMENT IS A KEY ELEMENT
HERE THAT THERE IS AN INDUSTRY
FUNDED PROGRAMS CDFA THAT THAT
MANAGES THE FOOD SAFETY AND THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
OF THE OTHER COMMODITIES DON'T
HAVE ANY ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
BE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TEN TO
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS.
ACCORDING THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT SO
THOSE ARE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
THE DIFFERENCES AND. OF THE
REASON THAT CALIFORNIA
GREENFIELD PACIFICUS READING
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS A SPECIAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX
FELONIES FELONIES GROUP ON
BEHALF OF VOICE FOR CHOICE
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WELL YOU KNOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF BILL.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SO TWO OF YOU WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK AND THEN IF YOU COULD JUST
DO THE IDENTIFICATIONS AFTER
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
HER THINK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE WITH YOU MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
MARLON FROM THE HUMANE SOCIETY
OF THE UNITED STATES. AND I
THINK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF EP THIRTY TWENTY
ONE.
AT THE ON SITE IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT EP THIRTY TWENTY ONE.
IS AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
TO AMEND PROPOSITION TWO.
IT'S PAST IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE DOES
NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO AMEND
THE INITIATIVE. UNLESS THE
INITIATIVE GRANTS THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO SO.
AB THIRTY TWENTY ONE AMENDS PROP
TWO BY REDEFINING THE AMOUNT OF
SPACE. THAT FARMS ARE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE HAGGLING HENCE A
SUBJECT AT THE VERY HEART OF
PROP TWO.
OUR NEW BALLOT MEASURE KNOWN AS
THE PREVENTION OF CRUELTY TO
FARMED ANIMALS ACT. IS A WAY TO
PROPERLY AMEND PROP TWO. LEADING
NATIONAL AND STATE ANIMAL
PROTECTION FOOD SAFETY AND
CONSUMER ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AS HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIANS ARE IN SUPPORT.
TO PRESENT A CAGE FREE FUTURE
FOR EGG LAYING HENS BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH IS
THIRTEEN YEARS AFTER THE PASS OF
PROP TWO.
AND IT'S EVIDENT THOUGHTS I AM
SOME OF THE MOTIVATING FACTORS
HERE. ARE ARE THOSE IN THE AG
INDUSTRY THAT ARE PUSHING AB
TWENTY ONE IS BECAUSE OF OUR
BALLOT INITIATIVE. WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT WE'VE ALREADY
GATHERED ENOUGH SIGNATURES TO
QUALIFY THIS MEASURE FOR THE
BALLOT. IN FACT WERE LIKELY TO
SMELL HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
MORE SIGNATURES TO GET OUR
MESSAGE ON THE BALLOT. INITIAL
POLLING SHOWS THAT THE BALLOT
MEASURE IS IN SUPPORT BY
STAGGERING SEVENTY TWO PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
SIMPLY PUT CALIFORNIANS EXPECT
MORE HUMANE TREATMENT OF FARM
ANIMALS FOR SAFER FOOD SUPPLY
SYSTEMS.
THEY NO LONGER WANT TO SEE
PRODUCERS USING MISTER ACTION
AND DECEPTION TO CLING ON TO
CRAWL CAGES.
ARE BALLOT MEASURE COALITION
STAND STRUGGLING IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS EFFORT TO UNDERCUT OUR
INITIATIVE.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE LEGISLATORS
TO VOTE NO ON THIS LAST AND
HADN'T TO MAINTAIN A STOCK
STATUS QUO. THAT HAS LONG BEEN
REJECTED BY VOTERS THINK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR OF MY NAME IS
BRADLEY MILLER AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE HUMANE FARMING
ASSOCIATION.
THINK IT'S POOR IMPORTANT TO
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE IN CONTEXT
I CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN LOUD AND CLEAR. NOT
SIMPLY FOR CAGE FREE BUT FOR
CAGE FREE. BY TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN.
NOW ABOUT WHAT IS NOT COVERED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS THE
FACT THAT MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE AND TWO THE
BALLOT MEASURE. IS THE FACT THAT
BOTH OF THEM FAILED TO COMPLY
WITH PROPOSITION TWO.
THE AMOUNT OF SPACE THAT
CALIFORNIA HANDS WILL RECEIVE
MORE THAN THEY ARE GETTING RIGHT
NOW IS PRECISELY THIS AMOUNT OF
SPACE.
NOW THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
CONTENTIOUS ISSUE AND IT WAS AT
THE TIME OF PROPOSITION TWO BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. BOTH THE
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS OF PROP
TWO AGREED ON.
WAS A CALIFORNIA WOULD BE CAGE
FREE BY TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN.
AND THAT SPATIAL REQUIREMENTS
WOULD BE ENOUGH FOR THAT HANDS
TO SPREAD BOTH WINGS FULLY
WITHOUT ENCROACHING AIR TOUCHING
THE SIDES OF THE CAGE OR THEIR
HANDS.
AND WHILE.
THE PROPONENTS FAILED TO SPECIFY
AS WELL THEY SHOULD HAVE.
INTO THERE WAS COMMONALITY IN
AGREEMENT THAT THAT WOULD NEVER
BE LESS THAN A FOOT AND A HALF.
PER HAN.
IT IS LITERALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
TO COMPLY WITH PROPOSITION TWO
EITHER THROUGH THE BALLOT
MEASURE OR THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION BY PROVIDING ONLY
ONE SQUARE FOOT. OF PER BIRD.
AND THERE'S NO LOGIC TO ONLY
PROVIDING THEM THAT THAT YOU
WILL LOOK INTO LEGISLATION THEY
BREAK IT DOWN THEY SAY WELL
HANDS THAT ARE IN CERTAIN UNITS
WILL.
SUPPOSED TO GET ONE AND A HALF
SQUARE FEET.
BUT THEN IF YOU HAVE THE SAME
UNIT.
AND YOU THROW IN ANOTHER LEVEL.
YOU CAN CRAM THIRTY THREE
PERCENT MORE HANDS NOT ONLY ON
THAT ADDITIONAL LEVEL THAT YOU
ADD.
BUT ON ALL THE ANIMALS THAT ARE
ON THE GROUND AS WELL. THERE'S
NO HUMAN HEALTH RATIONALE FOR
THAT IN FACT INCREASE STOCKING
DENSITIES INCREASES A SEMINAR
PROBLEMS THAT WERE THE
MOTIVATION. FOR A LOT OF THESE
EFFORTS THAT WE'RE THE
MOTIVATION STATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE.
SO OF THEM THE APPROPRIATE THING
TO DO AND THE ONLY
CONSTITUTIONAL THING WE BELIEVE
AFTER CALIFORNIA OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED A BAN ON CAGES AND A
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF KATE SPACE AT
ONE POINT. A FIVE OF.
A TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN SQUARE
INCHES PER PER HAND.
IS TO.
SIMPLY DECLARE THAT CALIFORNIA
AT CAGES ARE ILLEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA AS OF NOW HOUSE OF
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BALLOT MEASURE
AND THE PROPONENTS OF THIS
LEGISLATION. IS THAT ONE SAYS
WELL LET'S IGNORE PROPOSITION
TWO FOR A PERIOD OF SEVEN YEARS
AFTER IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ENACTED. AND THERE'S ANOTHER
PROPOSAL THAT SAYS NO THAT'S
ACTUALLY IGNORE IT. UNTIL THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
FOUR.
A BOTH ARE HOLDING INC
INAPPROPRIATE IT FLIES IN THE
FACE OF A MATTER THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DECIDED BY CALIFORNIA
VOTERS THEY DIDN'T GO TO THE
POLLS AND TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN SAY. YES WE WANT TO
GIVE LAYING HENS IN CALIFORNIA
ONE SQUARE FOOT.
AND WE WANT THEM OUT OF CAGES IN
THE YEAR CAGE FREE.
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
ENACTMENT DATE AND THERE IS NO
LEGITIMATE REASON FOR FOR GOING
AGAINST THAT.
I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SIR SHIELDS
AND I'M THE BEHAVIOR AND OFFER
SPECIALIST FOR HUMANE SOCIETY
INTERNATIONAL. I'M I DID FIND
TODAY FROM NEBRASKA IF IT'S OKAY
I'D LIKE TO SAY JUST A FEW WORDS
I LIKE TO DO THAT. APPRECIATE
YOU FLYING AND YEAH.
I'VE I DID MY DOCTOR WORK AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
DAVIS AND.
I WILL BE BRIEF AND AS YOU KNOW
THE CONFINEMENT OF FARM ANIMALS
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONSUMERS IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
AND THE ANIMALS OF COURSE.
AN INTENSIVE ANIMAL PROTECT
PRODUCTION IS THERE CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF IT THAT WE KNOW ARE
DETRIMENTAL TO WELFARE AND.
THERE'S AS A CLEAR SCIENTIFIC
BASIS FOR THIS IT'S NOT JUST AN
EMOTIONAL CONCERNS BASED ON
SCIENCE. YOU KNOW THE CABS AND
THE PIGS ARE CREATED INSTALLS
THAT ARE BARELY LARGER THAN
THEIR OWN BODIES THEY CANNOT
EVEN TURN AROUND. AND LAYING
HANDS ON THEIR KEPT IN SMALL
WIRE CAGES THEY CAN'T EVEN
SPREAD THEIR WINGS AND THESE
SYSTEMS PREVENT THE EXPRESSION
OF IMPORTANT NATIONAL BEHAVIOR
AND THEY HAVE REAL PHYSICAL
CONSEQUENCES ON THE WELFARE OF
THE ANIMALS.
AND THAT AFFECTS THEIR HEALTH
THAT AFFECTS THEIR WELL BEING
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN THEY CAN'T MOVE
THEY CAN GET JOINT DAMAGE
REDUCED MUSCLE WEIGHT AND
SKELETAL WEAKNESS.
PIGS NEED SEPARATE AREAS FOR
FEEDING AND FOR ARRESTING YOUNG
CABS M. THEIR VERY SOCIAL
ENERGETIC ANIMALS IF THEY'RE
TOOK A TETHERED IN A CRATE.
THEN.
THEY CAN ENGAGE IN NORMAL
SOCIAL BEHAVIOR SO YOU'RE EVEN
IF NO ONE IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
I'M SURE YOU DO BUT EVEN IF YOU
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE WELFARE OF
THE ANIMALS THAT SOMETHING THAT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS CARE ABOUT
VERY MUCH.
.
AB THIRTY TWENTY ONE IS POISED
TO UNDERMINE. ARE MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT TO TRY TO
BRING THESE ISSUES BACK TO THE
PEOPLE AND IT INCLUDES OUR
BALLOT INITIATIVE COULD INCLUDES
PIGS AND CABS AS WELL. AND
FORMER SEVERITY HAD MANY YEARS
TO COMPLY AND BUT AB THIRTY
TWENTY ONE DELAYS THAT
IMPLEMENTATION DATE EVEN FURTHER
BY TWO FULL YEARS AND SOME
COMPANIES LIKE SODEXHO ENCOMPASS
GROUP AND UNILEVER THEY HAVE.
INSTITUTED TIMELINES FOR.
ATTACK TRANSITION TO CAGE FREE
EGGS THEY NEED THEIR X. APPLY BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO OR EVEN
SOONER.
AND SO FOR THESE REASONS I I
URGE YOU TO REJECT A. B. THIRTY
TWENTY ONE AND INSTEAD LEAVE IT
TO THE VOTERS.
TO ENACT MORE COMPREHENSIVE
MEASURE NOVEMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HIGH CHAIR CABALLERO AND I
EVERYONE ON THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU I'M JUDY MAN CREW CELL AND I
AM THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION. AND I BET ON THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD FOR
EIGHT YEARS NOW THAT I AM VERY
PROUD.
AN HONOR TO SERVE AND WHEN
SPEAKER PEREZ APPOINT ME TO THE
BOARD HE SAID YOU KNOW JUDY YOU
HAVE AN IMPORTANT VOICE BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE DO CARE. ABOUT
ANIMALS AND WHY I'M HERE TODAY
IS WHEN WE PUT THIS BILL ONLINE
THROUGH OUR WEBSITE AND LET
PEOPLE KNOW.
THE LETTERS HAVE BEEN COMING IN
ALMOST EVERY MINUTE AGAINST THIS
BILL PEOPLE ARE FOR. ANTI
CONFINEMENT ANTI CRUELTY SO I
KNOW THE LINES GET BLURRED HERE
BECAUSE YOU HEAR FROM AG SPECIAL
INTEREST FOR THEM IT IS A BOTTOM
LINE ISSUE. BUT FOR THE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S MUCH MUCH MORE THAN THAT
AND PEOPLE WHO EAT CHICKEN .
ALL THESE ANIMALS THEY DON'T
WANT THE CRUELTY ON THE WAY.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO WHAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE MENTIONED
REGARDING HIS LAST BILL HIS LAST
BILL HE ASKED YOU.
TO.
TO OF RESPECT THE VOTERS.
OPINION AND.
AS THE VOTERS ON THE LAST BILL
HE PRESENTED.
SPOKE OUT FOR MARIJUANA THEY
SPOKE OUT FOR AGAINST CRUELTY IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR PERCENT.
OTHER VOTERS IT WAS A HISTORIC
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO EVER VOTED
FOR A PROPOSITION THANK YOU. SO
WE SAY KICK THIS BILL LET THIS
NEXT PROPOSITION THEY MANY OF
THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
BUT YOUR CAREER OF MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE WILSON I AM AN
ATTORNEY FOR MERCY FOR ANIMALS
MAY SAY A FEW WORDS I KNOW YOU
KNOW WHAT I'VE LET FOUR PEOPLE
TALK IT'S A LOT MORE THAN HE WAS
GONNA LET. IF YOU COULD JUST
MAKE IT TELL US YOUR NAME AND
YOU YOU I'M ASSUMING YOUR POST
AND I NEED TO GET. THIS
COMMITTEE MOVING AND I'VE GOT TO
GO VOTE IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW SO MANY TURN IT OVER
TO THE VICE CHAIR SO. I'M AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
HAS QUESTION AT OPPORTUNITY ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR AND THEN
HE CAN COME CONCLUDE. BY SO
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF SAY AGAIN I'M
STEPHANIE WILSON ON BEHALF OF
MERCY FOR ANIMALS WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO ANYONE ELSE.
SING OUT NO ONE ELSE ARE THERE
QUESTIONS OF THAT COMMITTEE.
MR MATHESON I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO YOU MR MATHIS I'VE GOT
TO GO BACK IN AND OTHER
COMMITTEE AND I'LL BE RIGHT
BACK.
THE FIRST.
MISTER LEVINE THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS I'VE TALKED WITH THAT
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE INDUSTRY.
YOU ARE VERY EAGER TO GIVE
THEIR BIRDS A LITTLE MORE SPACE.
.
THOUGHT I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR. ON JUNE JUST
SITTING HERE ON MY PHONE PLAYING
UP MY LOCAL TRACTOR SUPPLY OR
HAS OVER US SIXTY DIFFERENT
TYPES.
THAT THAT WE CAN GET IT AND
ANYBODY WHO'S ACTUALLY SPEND
TIME OUT OF THE CHICKEN RANCH
KNOWS THAT DEPENDING ON THE
BREED OF THE CHECK IN THEY ARE
DIFFERENT SHAPES AND SIZES. ARE
BASED UPON THE BREED.
SELL ON.
IS SAYING THAT YOU KNOW WHAT ONE
SPACE FOR FOR EVERYTHING OPERATE
ON ME IN YOUR VERY TECHNICAL
VERY QUICKLY BASED UPON YOU KNOW
WHETHER YOU WANT A RHODE ISLAND
RED OR. YOU KNOW LIKE HORNER OR
WHAT YOU WANT SELF.
.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
FROM MY SIDE CELL LEAVE IT AT
THAT ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
MR SONGS.
THANK YOU JUST COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND THEN.
MAYBE JUST COMMON AFTERWARDS
BUT.
MISTER LEVINE IS THERE ANYTHING
IN THIS BILL THAT PRIVATE SAID
CHICKEN FROM STANDING SITTING
HERE SPREADING ITS WINGS.
THERE ISN'T THIS WILL MEET
NATIONAL STANDARDS
INTO.
I THINK GIVE.
YOU KNOW FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
.
IT IT THE CARE THAT WE NEED TO
GIVE TO ANIMALS.
FOR THE KARMA THAT I INTO MY
CONSTITUENTS EXPECT.
AND THEN SECONDLY IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD WHICH WOULD PRECLUDE A
BALLOT INITIATIVE FROM GOING
VOTE.
IT DOES NOT AND IT ALSO IS NOT A
VIOLATION OF PROP TWO.
AND SO.
IN YOU SAID ALREADY IN YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT MAJOR RETAILERS
WERE MOVING TOWARDS THIS CAGE
FREE MODEL.
THIS IS THEIR ACTION THE
INDUSTRY IS GOING AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO GIVEN THE CONSTRAINTS
PROPOSITION TWO WHAT'S OUTLINED
IN THIS LEGISLATION DO YOU SEE
THAT IS IMPROVING FOOD SAFETY
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND.
OBVIOUSLY ANIMAL WELFARE IS WE
BASICALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I
THINK THAT WE'RE GONNA MEET THE
ALL THREE OF THOSE SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
I KNOW QUESTIONS COMMENT I MEAN
PROP TWO WAS WAS OF A WOMAN THE
SUCCESSFUL.
MINUTES IGNORANCE
INEFFECTIVENESS AND WHAT IT DID
DO WAS KILL ALL THE SMALL EGG
FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
THEM OUT OF BUSINESS WE GOT FROM
EIGHTEEN MILLION UNDER ELEVEN
MILLION.
AND SEND THOSE TO MEXICO. AND
OTHER STATES WHERE THEY HAVE.
WHERE THEY HAVE VERY INHUMANE?
TREATMENT OF OF THEIR HEADS
OTHER EGG LAYING HENS SO. BOTH
IGNORANT AND IF ANY EFFECTIVE.
THAT'S WHAT PROP TWO DID.
PUT YEAH RIGHT SIXTY FOUR
PERCENT OF THE VOTERS VOTED FOR.
.
PRIDE BECAUSE LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT. OF THE POPULATION
ACTUALLY IS ENGAGED IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS
THERE.
AND IS YOU KNOW VERY GOOD
STEWARDS VERY GOOD STEWARDS.
A OF THEIR HANDS.
AND.
SO YOU KNOW.
IT'S A TRAVESTY OR EVEN IN THIS
SITUATION IN THE FIRST PLACE BUT
PERHAPS.
PERHAPS MAYBE THE WAY TO DEAL
WITH THIS IS TO HAVE.
TWO DIFFERENT COMMISSIONS FOR
EXAM CALIFORNIA AND IT MAY BE
THAT THE TRULY TRULY PROP TO
CAGE FREE HAND. CAGE FREE A
COMMISSION AND THE CALIFORNIA
EGG COMMISSION WHICH HAS ALREADY
BEEN CREATED. BUT MAYBE THAT'S
WHERE WE CAN HANDLE THIS ISSUE
MORE EFFECTIVELY IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER ANY
OTHER MURDERS IN THE SEGMENT.
WELL JUST TO I REMEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT MOST THE MOST
BECAUSE WE SAID THAT CHICKENS
ONE DAYS ZERO SEE YOUR WE ALSO
OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED DOWN
MARRIAGE EQUALITY. I'M GLAD
WE'VE MADE LEGISLATIVE UPDATE
SINCE THEN.
A ITEM OF THE BILL THAT HAS BEEN
MOVED.
THAT I'VE HAVE A FIRST AND A
SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL.
I NAY THE THIRTY TWENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMEY RO. MATHIS
AYE MATHIS AYE AGUILAR CURRY
FLORA.
LARA AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAY. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE JONES SAWYER. LEVINE
AYE AYE LEVINE AYE SALAS. SOUTH
SIGN.
YOUR BILLS OUT THEY VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE.
BRITAIN
YEAH IT'S BEEN.
YEAH
BECAUSE
THE WORD.
AND ALSO AND.
PROGRESS TERRACE ISRAEL OR.
EARLIER.
FOR FOR TRAINING AND THEN NOW.
CAREFUL.
EVEN THOUGH THE.
I THINK IT.
PRESENT.
AS I HAD.
ALL.
ONE OF THE BILL ON.
SEC.
THAT'S A.
HI.
RUNNING BACK AND FORTH.
AB EIGHT HUNDRED YOU THE CLIP
NOW THAT. HYDROPONIC.
OKAY.
YEAH I GOT.
IRWIN.
I'M MEMBERS IF YOU.
SEATS BACK ON THE DYESS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE FORWARD.
.
WITH THE BE TWENTY ONE SIX
SIX.
THE CHAIRS BILL AND THEN SHE
WILL ALSO BE.
AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN MISS
IRWIN SPILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SIX
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BILL.
THIS THIS CALIFORNIA FARM BILL
HAS THREE CORE TENANT
FIRST IT IMPROVES THE STATE'S
STANCE TOWARDS THE BUSINESS OF
AGRICULTURE.
AND AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY HAS SEEN
DRAMATIC CHANGES IN HOW IT MUST
OPERATE.
FOOD SAFETY CONCERN FROM THE
CONSUMER. STATE REGULATIONS ON
PESTICIDE WATER ENERGY SOIL AND
WORKERS AND IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS A DRAMATIC CHANGE IN
AVAILABLE WORKERS REGARDLESS OF
WAGES AND OVERTIME A LOT OF THIS
YOU HEARD EARLIER TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BILL TAKES
ACTION TO IMPROVE THE STATE AND
INDUSTRIES WORKING RELATIONSHIP
TODAY.
BY EASING REGULATORY CONFLICTS
WITH THE CREATION OF A CD OF
FATE LED MULTI AGENCY REVIEW
COUNCIL. TO IDENTIFY AND
RECOMMEND RESOLUTION WHEN
COMPLIANCE WITH ONE REGULATION
POTENTIALLY CREATES CONFLICT
WITH ANOTHER.
IT FUNDS FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CDF FACE INVASIVE
PLANT AND PEST MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS FUNDS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
CALIFORNIA GROWN MARKETING
AGREEMENT.
FUNDS ONE POINT FIVE MILLION TO
CDFA FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
CENTRALIZED AG BUSINESS PORTAL.
AND REQUIRES THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT.
TO DEDICATE RESOURCES TO CAPTURE
THE FARM TO FORK ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF AGRICULTURE.
SECOND IT CREATES A STATE WIDE
AG INNOVATION PLATFORM.
AG AND BROUGHT CALIFORNIA ARE
INTRINSICALLY INTERTWINED AND AS
GOES AG SO GOES RURAL
CALIFORNIA.
WANTED TO IMPROVE ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS FOR RURAL RESIDENTS
IN MY COMMUNITY AND AT FIRST AT
MY THOUGHT WAS THAT IT WAS GOING
TO BE AG TOURISM. BUT I QUICKLY
REALIZED THAT THE AG INDUSTRY.
QUESTIONS ITS SURVIVAL IN THE
STATE AND THAT LEAVING.
AND THAT LEAVING WILL BE A DEATH
BLOW TO RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
EFFORTS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GASES SO IT IS NOT ABOUT ACTORS
THEM AT THE GROUND LEVEL IT'S
ABOUT SAVING ACT SO THAT THERE
CAN BE ACTORS IN THE FUTURE.
I REALIZE THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
SWEEP AND HEALTHY SOILS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED. TIMELY GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT DO NOT SCALE. AG
TECH ACROSS ALL FARM SIZES AND
TYPES BUT THEY HAVE PROGRAMS
THAT IMPROVE AG PRACTICES SO I
SUPPORT THOSE. AG TENT TECH IS A
NASCENT TECHNOLOGY VERTICAL THE
CYCLE OF VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING.
COMPANY GROWTH AND WEALTH
CREATION THROUGH MERGERS
ACQUISITIONS ARE STOCK OUR
OFFERINGS IS JUST BEGINNING. THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WEALTH CREATION
IN RURAL AREAS THROUGH AG TECH
ISRAEL IF CALIFORNIA CAPTURES AG
TECH FOCUS VENTURE CAPITAL
DOLLARS UNDER MANAGEMENT. AND IS
HOME TO AG TECH INNOVATORS AND
START UP COMPANIES.
AND BE AN EXAMPLE IS THE BUT IS
THE BLUE RIVER TECHNOLOGIES
PRECISION WEEDING. THROUGH
LASERS THAT LASERS THAT WAS
ACQUIRED BY JOHN DEERE. UP FOR
OVER THREE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS INTO TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHO KNEW THAT YOU
COULD DO THEY USE LASERS AT IT
TOO TO WEED. I USED TO GET PAID
TEN CENTS A BUCKET WHEN AS A KID
SO THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN TERRIFIC
LASERS.
THE CAP. PICK HIS HOW MUCH
CERTAIN THE CALIFORNIA OF FARM
BILL BRINGS BEST PRACTICES USES
CASES TOGETHER FIRST FOR A
STATEWIDE PLATFORM IT FINDS
TWENTY MILLION TO CDFA DID
DEVELOP THE AGRICULTURE
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION INSTITUTE.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
ITS MODELED OFF OF FOUR OTHER
STATE CREATED INSTITUTES
TO IDENTIFY AND COMMERCIALIZE
NASCENT TECHNOLOGIES INIS
INDUSTRIES IT FUNDS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUAL TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES DIVISION TO
HIRE AND RETAIN COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION EXPERT ADVISORS. AND
PROVIDES TAX INCENTIVE CREDITS
TO ADOPTERS OF AGRICULTURE
TECHNOLOGY. ONLY WHEN DEPLOYED
ON PRODUCING HARVESTABLE ACRES
WITH THE GOAL TO REDUCE ENERGY
WATER FERTILIZER PESTICIDE USE
OR TO AUTOMATE PLANTING THINNING
HARVESTING A PRODUCTION
SERVICES.
AND EXPANDS ON REGIONAL EFFORTS
IN IN THE STATE. I'M MOST
NOTABLY IN SALINAS FRESNO IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO AND DAVIS TO DEVELOP
TECHNOLOGY INCUBATORS AND
ACCELERATORS.
SO WHAT IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS IS
WE'RE FACING COMPETITION IN
OTHER STATES THAT ARE TRYING TO
DO THE EXACT SAME THING AND WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE. OUGHT WE ARE COMPETITIVE AND
THAT WE PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP
HERE. AND THIRD IT PROVIDES FOR
RURAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND SINCE THE
GREAT DEPRESSION BURKE
DEPRESSION CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY HAS BEEN AN EVEN RURAL
COMMUNITIES FEEL LIKE OR FOLLOW
THE FALLING FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND. SO THE IDEA WOULD BE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TRAIN RURAL
CALIFORNIA YOUTH. FOR FARMS OF
THE FUTURE AND IT CREATES MORE
FARMS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO BE
AG TECH SHOWCASES AND REAL WORLD
CAREER PATHS AND ENCOURAGES AG
TECH COURSEWORK EXPANSION. TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
SO.
WITH ME TODAY. DAY IN SUPPORT
IS BOB CORE REPRESENTING WEST
HILLS COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING A SMART FARM
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S TREMENDOUS.
JOHN COBB ASHIMA AT PHD
ENVIRONMENTAL HORTICULTURE
ADVISER EMERITUS YOU SEE
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION TO DISCUSS
THE NEED FOR CD CDF FACE
FUNDING.
AND.
HINT I YOU'RE NOT LOUIS BROWN.
BUT ALSO ALSO. HAVE SOMEONE WHO
IS THAT NO NO SECRET TO ANYBODY.
HEHE AT GLENDALE.
YOU MISSED AND AT WHO IS HAVE
YOU YOU SEE. A AND ARE AND
ALWAYS WANT TO SEE A DIFFERENT
LAST NAME BUT I ALWAYS HAVE TO
THINK OF HOW WAS IT SPELLED SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT DOT MY BILL.
I'M ROBERT OR FROM THE LOCAL
GROUP ON BEHALF OF WEST HILLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WERE
HONORED TO BE A SPONSOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BILL. CHANCELLOR
STEWART VAN HORN WHO COULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY EXTENDS THE DISTRICTS
PROFOUND GRATITUDE TO CHECK HAVE
A EURO. VICE PRESIDENT YOU MUST
IN AND SECRETARY RICE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL AND FOR
GETTING THEIR HANDS DIRTY BY
COMING DOWN TO COALINGA. LA MORE
IN FIREBAUGH ARE THREE CAMPUSES
TO WORK WITH US ON AG EDUCATION.
W. H. CCD FOR EIGHTY FIVE YEARS
A SERVANT OF VERSE.
NEW AND WONDERFUL STUDENT
POPULATION WITH CTE LEADERSHIP
INCLUDING OUR NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED FARM IN THE FUTURE.
FOOD SECURITY AND PCA PROGRAMS
WE APPRECIATE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ROLE IN THIS
BILL AND THE EMPHASIS ON RURAL
ACT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. WE
WISH TO UNDERSCORE LANGUAGE
CALLING FOR SMART FARMS. AND ON
FARM WIRELESS BROADBAND ACCESS.
WEST HILLS IS WORKING WITH THE
AG TECH ROUNDTABLE YOU SEE A AND
R. CDFA U. S. D. A. P. YOU SEE
WESTERN GROWERS FOOD PRODUCERS
EMERGING TECH FUND AND OTHERS
INCLUDING THE CI A.
CUT CULINARY INSTITUTE OF
AMERICA YEAH.
ON IT ON A SURVEY WE DID LAST
YEAR WE DISCOVERED TWO THINGS
YOU NEED TO KNOW. THERE IS
VIRTUALLY NO.
ON FARM WIRELESS BROADBAND
SERVICE SUFFICIENT TO PROP POWER
TODAY'S ACT TECH IN THE SAN FRAN
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY REGION
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE FOOD
PRODUCING REGION IN THE COUNTRY
IF NOT THE WORLD. GROWERS DRIVEN
BY REGULATORY COMPLIANCE A
SUSTAINABLE AG MANAGEMENT AND
OTHER FACTORS UNANIMOUSLY.
WHAT BROADBAND WIRELESS ON FARM
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO YEARS SO
WITHOUT WIRELESS BROADBAND
ACCESS THERE IS NO AG TECH?
WITHOUT AG TECH THERE ARE NO
NEXT GEN JOBS FOR STUDENTS WITH
THE REGION'S LEADING EMPLOYER AS
A DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR TOLD THE
ROUNDTABLE. THE INFORMATION
HIGHWAY IN RURAL CALIFORNIA IS A
RUTTED DIRT ROAD. WE ARE DRIVE
OUT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'M DOCTOR JOHN COBB SHIMA YOU
SEE CORPORATE DISSENSION ADVISOR
EMERITUS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SIX
SPECIFICALLY OF THE FUNDING FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S STATEWIDE PLANT
PEST PREVENTION AND MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM.
HAS A VICE PRESIDENT WHO MUST
AND MENTIONED EARLIER ON JULY
ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH. WE HAD
INVASIVE SPECIES SOMEWHAT HERE
AT THE STATE CAPITOL.
AND OF THE.
SUMMIT.
SPECIFICALLY ARE ADDRESSED
THE NEEDFOR BRINGING OUR PEST
BENSON PROGRAM THE TO TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. AND SPECIFICALLY
RECOMMENDED INCREASING THE
DOLLARS
FOR THE PAST PREVENTION. OF
PLAN.
.
DURING MY CAREER I HAVE WORKED
IN THE. LAST FORTY YEARS.
ON ALMOST EVERY MAJOR INVASIVE
PESTS THAT IS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE WORKED O. WITH CDFA AND
AND WHAT ITS PARTNERS SUCH AS
USDA. DOWN I I MUST ADMIT AT
TIMES I WAS HIGHLY CRITICAL BUT
THE MAJORITY TO TIMES I BELIEVE
WE HAVE.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE BEST.
SYSTEMS IN THE WORLD.
IN FACT.
WHEN I TRAVEL AROUND THE WORLD
WE ARE. BROUGHT UP AS AN
EXAMPLE.
OF HOW YOU DEAL WITH INVASIVE
PESTS.
AND I I THINK THAT. THOUGH
FUNDING CUTS THROUGH THE YEARS
HAVE DRAMATICALLY REDUCED OUR
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN THAT
POSITION.
WE HAVE SEEN. RECENTLY IN IT
INCREASE AS OF US PRESENT HIM
SOME MENTION IN PAST COME IN AND
TO CALIFORNIA AND WE SEEM AN.
INCREASE IN THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE PESTS THAT OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A SMALL WORLD THAT WE
LIVE IN WE HAVE.
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN I WAS A.
A YOUNG MAN I THINK IT WAS A FEW
MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE HUGE URBAN FOREST.
THAT WOULD BECOME THE NEW
PATHWAY FOR INVASIVE SPECIES
TO ENTER CALIFORNIA BUILD UP TO
TREMENDOUS NUMBERS AND EXPLODE.
NOT ONLY INTO AGRICULTURE BUT
INTO THE URBAN FORCING RIPARIAN
FORESTS.
WE ARE NOW FACING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF DAMAGE OF. OF NOT
ONLY. THE INTRODUCED PLANT
SPECIES THAT WE FIND IN OUR
LANDSCAPES BUT ALSO OUR NATIVE
SPECIES.
ARE.
ONE PASSED THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH RIGHT NOW THE SHUTTLE
BOARDS.
OUR NOW HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ESTABLISH THEMSELVES AND SIXTY
THREE REPRODUCTIVE POLLS.
MANY OF THEM NATIVE SPECIES.
AND THE SAN DIEGO. THEY HAD.
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
WILLS WHAT'S IS THE. OF.
HABITAT FOR INVASIVE SWIMMING
FOR A HOME. ENDANGERED SPECIES.
AND THAT.
THAT TIJUANA RIVER WAS WIPED OUT
IN NINE MONTHS.
BECAUSE WE ALLOW THIS PAST TO
BUILD UP IN THE URBAN
ENVIRONMENT AND HOW DOES THAT
HAPPEN. WELL NUMBER ONE WE HAVE
HUGE URBAN FORCE AND NUMBER TWO
WE HAVE.
THE INABILITY OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO
RESPOND HAS TO HISTORICALLY HAVE
RESPONDED. BECAUSE OF THE CUTS
THAT THEY'VE HAD TO ENDURE. AND
IF USDA DOESN'T BRING AND
QUARANTINED.
QUARANTINES AND OUR DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THE QUARANTINE THAN CDFA
IS NO LONGER. IN A POSITION TO
RAPIDLY RESPOND TO THE INVASIVE
SPECIES
BUT THE PLOY PROGRAMS THAT BEEN
SO SUCCESSFUL IN THE PAST.
SO. I I'M ASKING AND URGING THIS
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE.
PORK THE FUNDING FOR THE PLANT
PREVENTION.
PORTION OF SEATED BASED BUDGET
SO THAT THEY CAN REBUILD AND
ALSO. THERE ARE THERE HAVE BEEN
TREMENDOUS STRIDES IN
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT OUR ABILITY TO IDENTIFY AND
TO ADDRESS.
AND. INVASIVE PASSED
AND WE WILL NEED. A INFUSION OF
DOLLARS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT AND TO BRING US UP BACK UP
TO THE LEVEL WE NEED TO BE FOR
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ES SAID EARLIER MONEY WAS GOING
TO HUMUS DENY SERVICE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR AG NATURAL
RESOURCES. I'M THRILLED TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY EARLIER TODAY TO
OFFER SOME OVERVIEW COMMENTS
ABOUT AGRICULTURE NATURAL
RESOURCES ARE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
AND WHAT WE DO.
I'M HIT THRILLED TO BE HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
HOWEVER I MUST STATE THAT I'M
SPEAKING TODAY AS AN INDIVIDUAL
EXPERT WITHIN MY FIELD. AND A
PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL NOT AN
OFFICIAL REPRESENTATIVE OF YOU
SEE.
WE ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
CHAIR CABALLERO SUPPORT AND
INTEREST IN REBUILDING
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
IT'S TRUE THE NUMBER OF
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION ADVISORS
HAS FALLEN DRASTICALLY OVER THE
PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS. IN FACT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE APPROXIMATELY
HALF
THE COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
SPECIALIST AND ADVISERS THAT WE
HAD TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
WITH DRAMATIC BUDGET CUTS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DURING
THE NINETEEN NINETIES RECESSION
AND THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
ECONOMIC CRISIS WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE NUMBERS OF
ADVISORS WE ONCE HAD.
SOME OF THIS IS BECAUSE A IN OUR
IS A DIVISION WITHIN THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT. AND AS
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
BUDGET IS CUT IT AFFECTS THE
PROGRAM SUCH AS COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION AND FOR H..  AND
OTHER PROGRAMS.
THE FUNDING IN THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE
NEW SPECIALIST AND ADVISERS AND
ALLOW US TO TARGET THOSE TO SOME
OF THE MOST SEVERE CHALLENGES.
ARE FARMERS AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE CURRENTLY FACING
DROUGHT CLIMATE CHANGE INVASIVE
SPECIES NATURAL DISASTERS AND
MORE.
THAT SAID I MUST ALSO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT THE UC DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL AS OF THIS
TIME.
WE ARE VERY ENGAGED WITH OTHER
PARTS OF THE BILL SUCH AS
INVASIVE SPECIES AND DEVELOPING
NEW TECHNOLOGIES FRAG WHICH I
TOOK PART IN MY EARLIER POST
MONEY. SO AGAIN THANK YOU AND I
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO SEE A
CALIFORNIA FARM BILL ON THE
TABLE TO SHARE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE OUT THERE
IN SUPPORT.
AARON.
EHRENREICH VERY GOOD CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALMONDS GRAIN AND FEED
EGGS FARMERS FLORAL WHEAT
GROWERS BEING SHIPPERS PAIRS
POULTRY SEEDS AND THE WAREHOUSE
ASSOCIATION.
SECURE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL INSUPPORTABLE.
MOST ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
SEEN IN A YEAR NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OF OPPOSITION.
NOT IN OPPOSITION TO BE CLEAR WE
JUST SHARED A LETTER OF CONCERN
THIS MORNING WITH STAFF AND ARE
EXCITED ABOUT SOME ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE BILL.
AYE WE SHARED A FEW POINTS THAT
WERE INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO
DISCUSS WITH BE OUR AUTHOR
MOVING FORWARD.
ONE JUST TO SAY WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT A CALIFORNIA FARM
BELT WE THINK IT'S NOT REALLY
EXCITING MOMENT IN CALIFORNIA TO
BE THINKING ABOUT. ARE THE
LEADERSHIP THAT A FARM BELT CAN
PROVIDE OPTICALLYON THE EVE OF
A FEDERAL FARM BILL BEING
DISCUSSED.
BUT IN PARTICULAR WE SEE A FEW
POINTS MISSING ONE I'M WE FEEL
THAT ANY CONVERSATION AROUNDS A
FARM BILL AND AROUND FARMING IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD INCLUDE A
DISCUSSION AROUND FOOD. PROPERTY
CLEAN SOME OF THE BOB RURAL
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF
THE ARE SOME OF THE POOREST
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE SOME OF THE MOST FOOD
INSECURE. AND SO WAS THE LOOK AT
THAT MARRIAGE OF FOOD AND
FARMING WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE FOOD NEEDS AND SOME OF OUR
RURAL COUNTIES.
I WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS DIRECTION ON
AND THAT'S WHY WE CAN'T REMAIN
AGNOSTIC ON TECHNOLOGY AND SO.
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTINUE DISK DIRECTION AYE TO
THAT TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
INVESTMENTS IS ESSENTIAL. I'M
EXCITED ABOUT SERVE WATER THAT
THE PARAMETERS WE CAN PROVIDE
FOR THAT TECHNOLOGY.
WE ALSO MADE EXCITED AND AND
FULLY SUPPORT INVESTMENTS AND
YOU SEE COOPER EXTENSION BUT
ALSO WANT TO LOOK AT LARGER
INVESTMENTS IN SUSTAINABLE AND
CUTTING EDGE AGRICULTURE AND
WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO. IN THE U.
SEASON BEYOND TO MOVE
AGRICULTURE FORWARD IN THE
STATE.
AND FINALLY.
WE WERE WORRIED IN THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION THAT FARMWORKERS ARE
OVERLOOKED AND SO WANT TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
AROUND MAKING SURE THAT OUR
FARMWORKERS AND OTHER FOOD CHAIN
WORKERS ARE MORE INCLUDED IN THE
PROPOSAL.
SO I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THOSE
POINTS IN AND AGAIN ARE JUST
BEGINNING SOME CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND
EXCITED ABOUT MOVING THOSE
FORWARD ON BEHALF OF OPPOSITE
ACTION NETWORK AND. A BUNCH OF
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS LABOR
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE.
FOOD FOOD JUSTICE AS ADDRESSES
SIR COULD YOU SEE YOUR NAME AND
YEAH WE YES.
THANK YOU PAUL TOWERS I'M WITH
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK INTO A
BUNCH OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THINKS IT. CAN YOU LIST THOSE
OUT YET SO I DON'T THE LETTER
TODAY WE CIRCULATED IN RECORDS
OUT THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
RURAL STUDIES RATES OF CHANGE
OXNARD'S AN ECOLOGY CENTER
ENVIRONMENT WORKING GROUP. SO
FOOD CALIFORNIA UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN SEATS
COUNCIL. ACCOUNT COMMITTEE
LIJSTTREKKER ECOLOGY.
ECOLOGY CENTER CHAMAELEONTIS
OUR COMPANY'S PRESS AT REFORM
AND AND SEVERAL OTHERS.
THANK YOU.
BUT JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF
OF ONE OF THE OTHER SIDE ON THAT
LETTER THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH.
THAT YOU THINK YOU.
THEY YOU ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
SCENE NINE REMOTE TO THE
COMMITTEE.
MR SOLID.
LIKE MR THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AB.
LEAVE THE MEASURES BEEN MOVED
ALL SECOND IF IT HAS BEEN SUCH A
GREAT LOVE BE ADDED AS CO AUTHOR
THINK YOU'D APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS IN PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU.
I TOO WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR. THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT YOU GET OUT OF
THIS THING IS THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE IN THE ROOM IF YOU'VE NEVER
EXPERIENCED SOMEONE HAS BEEN FOR
H..
IT IS A CREDIBLE PLACE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO LEARN ABOUT
AGRICULTURE TO LEARN ABOUT
LEADERSHIP. MY VERY FIRST AWARD
I EVER RECEIVED ITS IN MY OFFICE
WOULD LET HIM SEE IT. IS I WON A
AWARD WITH FOR H. FOR.
DEMONSTRATION THAT I DID ON
SEWING I KNOW IT'S TOUGH TO
BELIEVE US SO.
BUT I I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT I LIKE THE
TECHNOLOGY I THINK WE NEED. TO
CONTINUE THAT THE BROADBAND AS
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WE GOT A
BROADBAND BILL.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION HAD ABOUT HOW WE
DO THIS.
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE'S A LOT OF
PIECES TO THIS A PIE FOR
AGRICULTURE WHETHER THROUGH USDA
THROUGH OF THIS RURAL HOUSING
WHATEVER WE DO NEED TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE A
ROBUST SYSTEM FOR US. FOR THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY.
INTEGRATED PEST PEST MANAGEMENT
A MY GOD AND LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE.
CITIES DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT MEANS BUT PART ONE THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS THAT WE
CAN HAVE IN THIS ROOM SO. I
SUPPORT A REAL THANK YOU FOR
BRING UP FOR AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING IF YOU'RE GONNA. YOU
KNOW.
MOVE AFFORD ANY OTHER HUESO
THANK YOU I AM OFFERING THIS
BILL FOR GUY.
I THINK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
SELL.
I I KNOW MY OFFICE IS BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH YOUR OFFICE.
I LOVE THIS BILL.
SO MUCH I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GET IT RIGHT. THERE ARE A FEW
SMALL PIECES THAT I KNOW WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON.
AND TELL WE GET THOSE.
DON AND SETTLED ON THAT A
LAYOFF.
BECAUSE I WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THAT WE HAVE THE
DISCUSSION THOUGH THE WORK IS
GREAT. THIS IS MONEY MINUTES FOR
OUR STATE TO HAVE AN AG BILL.
YOU ON ON EXTREMELY SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE.
GET IT DONE RIGHT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD
WHICH IS WHY I'M LAYING OFF.
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND TO.
CHAU THAT THERE ARE STILL A FEW
PIECES ON WHAT THE TECH SECTOR.
ON SITE ON THIS IN A FEW OF THE
OTHER WAYS WITH THE COMPETITIVE
GRANTS AND THINGS THAT I WANT TO
SEE FIX.
BEFORE WE MOVE.
AND WITH THAT.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER COMMENTS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
COMEY RO BY.
I MATHIS NOW VOTING.
MATH IS NOT LOADING AGUILAR
CURRY. A YEAR CURRY AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GALLAGHER.
GREAT.
GRAY AYE EGGMAN.
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE SALAS. SALAS
SIGN.
THE OTHER.
BILLS OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PUZZLED IT I BELIEVE.
MISTER TING IS BEHIND USES LIKE
IF I COULD JUST PICK UP ON IT
MISS IRWIN YEAH LET'S LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD WITH MY
SERMONS. SURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO.
MOVE THE BILL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU IT IS THERE
ON THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR AB
TWENTY SHARE THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN.
PLEASE JUST A STATE YOUR NAME
AND.
WHERE FROM?
SHE.
A SURE.
MENEM'S BRIAN SHIPMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMB IN AGRICULTURE
NETWORK.
CAL CAN WORSE THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
.
IT AND NUMBER. DAVID OVERLY.
WITH WILSON VINEYARDS AND WINE
IN CLARKSBURG.
AND IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
ANY OTHERS ARE OUT THERE IN
SPPORT.
OR OR IS THIS OPPOSITION.
SUPPORT TIM SMELLS OR.
REPRESENTING WINE INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER HEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY AND
SUPPORT.
MILLION.
REBECCA MARCUS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT.
KRISTIN MURPHY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT.
ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
MICHAEL DIMMICK VIA IN SUPPORT
FOR WHICH A CHANGE.
AND DAVE BRUNSON COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO I HAVE A QUICK COMMENT.
I'VE A LOT OF SMALL FARMERS IN
MY DISTRICT A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THIS BEEN THIS
BILL WOULD REALLY HELP THEM. MY
ONLY CONCERN IS WHETHER OR NOT
FIFTEEN PERCENT IS TOO HIGH.
I KNOW THIS WE PROGRAMS
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE TAKING
AWAY FROM.
ALREADY LIMITED GRANT FUNDING
I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
BUT I'D LIKE TO VOICE MY CONCERN
FOR THAT PIECE THE FIFTEEN
PERCENT.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT I LIKE TO AYE ECHO MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILLING THIS IS
A GREAT WAY TO USE AYE CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS TO HELP OUR SMALL
FARMERS AND GROWERS GET THE
TECHNOLOGICAL SINCE THEY NEED.
TO MEET ON COMING REGULATIONS
SO THIS IS SPENDING MONEY. I I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT WHEN THE
STATE SAYS WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING THEY NEED TO BACK UP
THE FUNDS TO DO SO ON THIS IS A
GREAT WAY TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
NOT. LEAVING OUR SMALL FARMERS
OUT SHELVE THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING ON BEHALF MISTER.
WELCOME SECRETARY PLEASE KALRA.
ON AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
THE MOTION AS DO PASSED NATURAL
RESOURCES.
KELLY RO. CON THE ORAL AYE
MATHIS BY MATHIS SIGH AGUILAR
CARRY. A YEAR CURRY AYE FLORA.
LARA AYE GALLAGHER.
GRAY.
I PLAY AYE EGGMAN.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE SALAS. SALAS
SIGN BUILT.
BILLS OUT MISTER TEEN.
IF YOUR READY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FIVE MAYBE
GET.
MOVE THE BILL.
I THANK YOU AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FIVE CRYPTOGRAM PROGRAM
WAS CDFA. TO HELP CORNER STORES
ANOTHER SMALL STILL SKILLS WAS
OF LIMITED SELECTION OF FOOD
PRODUCTS.
PURCHASE ENERGY EFFICIENT
REFRIGERATION THE COUNTIES AND
ALAMEDA.
LA SAN DIEGO SAN FRANCISCO I
HAVE TWO VERY PATIENT WITNESSES
HAVE BEEN HERE SINCE ONE THIRTY.
THANK YOU.
WHO ALL MAKE A VERY BRIEF?
TESTIMONY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HEARING
LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY MY NAME
IS AMY DILISIO NUMBER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE CENTER FOR
WELLNESS NUTRITION. AND I'M A
REGISTERED DIETITIAN BY TRAINING
AND HAVE WORKED ON IN
COMMUNITIES ON NUTRITION
EDUCATION AND INTERVENTIONS FOR
THE PAST TWELVE YEARS.
I AM VERY PLEASED TO SPEAK TO
YOU ABOUT HEALTHY RETAIL
INITIATIVES TODAY AND THE IMPACT
THEY HAVE ON COMMUNITIES AND
INCREASING ACCESS TO FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES AND HEALTH. LOOKING
UNIT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
HIGH RATES OF OBESITY IN THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOODS
ESPECIALLY FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES.
THE GOAL OF HEALTHY RETAIL
INTERVENTIONS IS TO EXPAND THE
QUALITY AND QUANTITY OF FRESH
FOODS FOR CONSUMERS AND IN TURN
MAINTAIN OR INCREASE.
SALES FOR SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
THE MAJORITY OF PURCHASING
DECISIONS ARE MADE IN THE STORES
SO HAVING HEALTHY FOODS. EASILY
AVAILABLE FOR CUSTOMERS HELPS TO
INFLUENCE HEALTHY FOOD
PURCHASES.
IN SACRAMENTO SMALL STORE OWNERS
RECEIVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SMALL INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
THE STOCKING AND SALES OF FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES. HAVE A
FEW EXAMPLES SO AN EXAMPLE IS A
THREE TIERED BASKET PLACE NEAR
THE CHECKOUT FILLED WITH FRESH
FRUITS.
I'M WITHIN ONE WEEK THE STORE
OWNER REPORTED THAT THEY HAD TO
RESTOCK THE POTUS AND NOTED THAT
THE PIOUS SOLD OUT VERY QUICKLY.
AND ANOTHER INSTANCE THE STORE
OWNER RECEIVED A SMALL
REFRIGERATOR FOR FREE AN
AGREEMENT TO STOCK IT WITH
HEALTHY. FOOD PRODUCTS
HE MADE HIS OWN OF SALADS AND
FRESH CUT FRUIT INSIST CREATED
HIS OWN HEALTHY FOOD LABELS HE
WAS EXCITED TO SUPPORT ITS
CUSTOMERS HEALTHY REPORTED.
PROFITABLE SALES EIGHTY FOUR
PERCENT OF PURCHASES AT SMALL
STORES ARE FOOD OR BEVERAGES
THAT ARE ALMOST CONSUMED
IMMEDIATELY SO HAVING ACCESS TO
FRESH HEALTHY READY TO EAT FOODS
IS VERY IMPORTANT. FOR
COMMUNITIES MANNERS TO PICK
HEALTHIER CHOICES AND IS ALSO
MANY STORIES NEED HOPE.
HOW THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO CARRY
THESE PERISHABLE ITEMS?
ALSO ANOTHER RESULT OF A HEALTHY
RETURN INITIATIVE AND HOW LOS
ANGELES WE LEARNED EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT OF CUSTOMERS NOTICED
HEALTHY SIGNAGE AND SEVENTY TWO
PERCENT OF THOSE CUSTOMERS.
CHANGE THEIR PURCHASING PATTERNS
BASED ON THESE AND PURCHASE
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES AT LEAST
ONCE.
PER WEEK FROM THE SMALL STORE.
OWNERS WERE MOST INTERESTED IN
BEING ABLE TO OFFER DISCOUNT
COUPONS AS A STRATEGIC
COMPLEMENT IN STORE CHANGES IN
MOSTAR OWNERS ARE INTERESTED IN
CARRYING HELP MORE OF BROADER
SELECTION OF HEALTHY FOODS. IN
EXCHANGE.
.
BUT THEY HAD A BARRIER IN
SOURCING OF FRESH PRODUCE.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CONNECTIONS TO AFFORDABLE
DISTRIBUTORS WERE IDENTIFIED AS
NEEDS.
IN CLOSING HEALTHY RETAIL
PROGRAMS ARE MAKING IMPACT
ACROSS THE STATE AND PROVIDING
ACCESS TO FRESH PRODUCE
OTHERWISE THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT BE THERE.
INCREASING HEALTHY FOOD
PURCHASING FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND ENCOURAGING
PARTICIPATION OF LOCAL CORNER
STORES IS A WIN WIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IN A AN
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE REBEKAH
DELAURO SO WITH LATINO COALITION
FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. AND WE
ARE. PROD CO SPONSOR OF THE
LEGISLATION.
EXCITED THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM IS EXPANDING THAT THE
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
.
LCH THE WE TAKE A BROAD APPROACH
TO HEALTH BY ADDRESSING THE
SOCIAL ECONOMIC DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH.
WHICH INCLUDE OF MORE BROADER
APPROACHES TO GETTING OUT THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CHRONIC DISEASE.
IN CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
IT LATINO COMMUNITIES ARE.
RELATED TO CHRONIC DISEASE SO
WE FEEL THAT THIS IS A
INNOVATIVE SOLUTION TO REALLY
GET AT THE ROOT CAUSE.
OF.
POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES.
SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES ARE THE LATINO
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE.
IDENTIFIER ANDREA AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE OTHER SALADA
MOMENTUM IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE WORK
AND.
AT LC EACH HE IS TO INCREASE
ADVOCACY CAPACITY AMONG THE THE
LATINO COMMUNITY.
SPECIALLY WITH A OUR YOUTH
THROUGH OUR HOUSE HELP
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM A WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO.
WORK WITH FOR EXAMPLE.
OPENNESS ON THOSE I WHICH IS A
HEALTH.
USE ORGANIZATION BASED OUT OF
WATSONVILLE THAT HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN PARTNERING WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES.
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE CORNER STORES ARE ABLE TO
RECONFIGURE.
THERE.
.
AREAS THAT THEIR BUSINESSES TO
MAKE THE HEALTHIER CHOICES THESE
ARE CHOICES IN THE COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE EXCITED TO COLLABORATE
AGAIN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AND THEIR PARTNERS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ENABLE.
VERY GOOD IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MICHAEL TO MAKE RICHARD CHANGE
AS A CO SPONSOR WE.
JR YES FOR.
COOL ACCOUNTING WITH THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN STROKE ASSOCIATION AND
WE ARE AT YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
ARMONK TINSMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RENNSPORT NECESSARILY COULD
SMALL BUSINESS BILL.
DAVE RUNS AND CAMINO IT'S WITH
FAMILY FARMERS WE SUPPORT.
I NEVER SEE MY NAME THIS TIME
PAUL TOWERS WITNESSES THAT
ACTION NETWORK AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
HI ACTUALLY ATILLA BRUSH WITH
HELP FROM FARM BUREAU WHERE IT.
AND SO CERTAINLY WE WANNA THANK
WITH SEARCHING FOR BEING A
LEADER IN THIS ISSUE
INSECURITIES A HUGE PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S BEEN REALLY
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING SEEN UP
DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIA WHICH ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF.
ENFORCEMENT DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ON THIS BILL.
AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW. ONLY
FOR A FIFTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
AS YOU ALL MAY KNOW ALMOST
EVERYONE OF YOUR RURAL COUNTIES
ARE REPRESENTED HERE. AND AND
THEY HAD EVEN MORE PRESSING FOR
ITS SECURITY ISSUES EVEN MORE
PRESSING FOR ACCESS ISSUES WITH
HIGHER DENSITY OR HIGHER
INTENSITY OF FOOD DESERTS.
WE WOULD ASK THAT THIS BE
BROADENED TO INCLUDE AN
ELIGIBILITY FOR RURAL COUNTIES
TO COMPETE THAT TO PLAY AN
ACTIVE ROLE IN A PILOT PROGRAM.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO HAVING
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR ON
THAT'S THANK YOUR IMAGE MAKE
VERY MUCH.
SORRY CHAIR MEMBERS CUT THE
MUSTARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES I MISS THE
SUPPORT MIND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THINK.
THE REMATCH.
KATE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
MATHIS.
BOB. BUT I YOU KNOW I I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE BILL BUT YOU KNOW
I MASS.
IF YOU HAVEN'T FIGURED IT OUT
YET. I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AT THE TABLE
ON THIS BILL AND IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY I'M I'M NOT GOING TO
CHANGE YOUR BILL TODAY BUT I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
RURAL COMMUNITIES. HAVE LOTS OF
FOOD DESERT'S
AND SMALL BUSINESS IS WHAT WE
LIVE OFF IN A ROW ME SO I JUST
WANTED TO THROW THAT OUT THE
FIVE WILL SUPPORT A BILL TODAY.
SO WE I'D I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
YOU. IF I COULD MISTER KING I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR A
DITTO ALTHOUGH I WAS JUST SAYING
YOU CAME TO THE WRONG COMMITTEE
AND JUST HAVING BECAUSE IT THE
BIG CITIES. EARLY GET THROUGH
THEM BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY
FEELS THE SAME WAY I WAS GONNA
CHANGE THE BILL BUT IT YOU JUST
GOTTA ADD SOME RURAL COMMUNITIES
MISTER SOLACE I JUST ON THAT
POINT I WAS JUST GOING TO ADD A
DOE.
ME MISTER TING ABOUT THIS
DISCUSSION AS WELL ABOUT THE
RULE AREAS IN THE FOOD DESERTS.
IN OUR DISCUSSIONS MISTREATING
SEEM VERY AMENABLE TO OPENING UP
TO COUNTIES THAT ACTUALLY HAD
THESE MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO
ACTUALLY EMBRACE THESE.
WE.
OUT. THESE PROGRAMS SO I'LL
SONGS THAT STILL THE CASE
RESTRICTING.
MR MATHIS.
DITTO UMDNJ LUCK THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ITSELF.
MY DISTRICT.
NOW IF YOU JUST LOOK AT TULARE
IN FRESNO COUNTIES THERE THAT TO
POOREST COUNTIES IN THE ENTIRE
STATE. THEY HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST LATINO POPULATIONS IN
THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND THEY'RE NOT INCLUDED.
.
I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT.
I THINK A LOT OF THE MEMBERS
APPEAR ON THE DIETS A LOT OF OUR
RURAL MEMBERS ARE NOT OKAY WITH
THAT AS WELL.
IN INTELLIGENCIA. THAT ADDED IN
WHERE ARE OTHER DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS THE STATE BESIDES JUST.
FOR COUNTIES ARE INCLUDED.
I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT AS WE LOOK AT
ASPECTS TO HELP WITH FOOD
INSECURITY.
HELP OUR LATINO POPULATIONS IS
AS WE TRY TO DO THESE THINGS
THAT WE AYE SHARE OUR
DISADVANTAGE ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE.
SO I WILL BE VOTING NO I URGE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO VOTE NOW AND TELL.
YOU GIVE US A COMMITMENTS.
TO TAKE SOME AMENDMENTS AND
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SO WE CAN
ADDRESS.
FOOD SECURITY WHERE IT TRULY
TRULY NEEDS THE HELP ACROSS THE
STATE.
WITHOUT JUST PICKING.
FOR COUNTIES.
THANK YOU.
IT IS SO RARE WE GET TO PICK ON
THE BIG CITY GAS.
IT'S NICE TO BE IN THE AG
COMMITTEE.
MR THING I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
SUPPORT YOUR BILL DAY BUT I I
WOULD ECHO THE. COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAD YOU THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE.
KEEP IN MIND OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES I KNOW YOU AND I
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER ON MANY
THINGS.
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA BUT HOPEFULLY WE CAN
FIND WAYS TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS LEGISLATION TO. ABBY
INCLUSIVE. OF RURAL CALIFORNIA
IS ONE.
CAN WE GET A COMMITMENT FROM YOU
TODAY THAT YOU WILL. AND MEN
THAT. SO SO THE CHAIR ASKED ME
TO WAIT TO RESPOND EVERYBODY
WOULD TELL EVERYONE SPOKE AND
I'M RESPECTING THE CHAIR.
MR FAR HAVE RESPONDED THREE
CHECK THINK THAT WAS THE LAST
ONE THAT I JUST WANTED EVERYBODY
GET THEIR PUNCHES IN BEFORE
PACKAGES. IN HOA BAG MISTER
MISTER GRAY'S YOU KNOW COME
RIGHT EFFORTS HARD WE COULD TAKE
A PUNCH.
I LOVE THE PREMISE OF THE BILL
ON THE BE LAYING OFF OF A TAKE
AND I LOVE TO SUPPORT IT ON THE
FLOOR BUT THANK YOU.
MISTER TING.
SO ARM THIS BILL THE THIRD TIME
A THIRD YEAR THAT I'VE RUN THIS
BILL IN THE IN THE PREVIOUS SINK
OUR CONSIDERATION IT WAS A
STATEWIDE BILL.
WE DID TRY TO USE OUR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MONEY FROM THE P. YOU
SEE BECAUSE IT WAS A LARGE POT
OF MONEY THAT DID NOT GET USED.
I THOUGHT IT WAS BETTER USE FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY LIKE
REFRIGERATION I THINK I AND IT
WAS A STATEWIDE BILL THAT WAS
NOT ON ANY COUNTIES.
SO WE DECIDED TO USE MAKE THIS
A PILOT DEL SO THIS IS REALLY A
PILOT BILL IT'S NOT A.
STATEWIDE BILL IN A STARTED OFF
AS A SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES
BILL BECAUSE THOSE WERE THE ONLY
TWO.
COUNTIES THAT WE KNEW ACTUALLY
HAD
EXISTING PROGRAMS SINCE THEN
ALAMEDA AND SAN DIEGO EXPRESSED
INTEREST. OUT WHAT I TOLD MR
SOLACE YESTERDAY BY PHONE AND I
WOULD SAY IF ANY OF YOU. IF
YOU'RE COUNTIES OR YOUR CITIES
HAVE. COME PROGRAMS THAT ARE A
LOT INTEREST WE WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM I
THINK WE WERE.
WE CHOSE THESE COUNTIES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE EXISTING PROGRAMS
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURES WHERE
THEY ARE WORKING WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES IN DOING
REFRIGERATION PROJECTS.
WE OBVIOUSLY ARE VERY SENSITIVE
TO FISCAL ISSUES IN DIDN'T WANT
TO GIVE COUNTIES MONEY THAT WE
DIDN'T WANT TO. DO THIS KIND OF
WORK.
SO IF THERE IS WORK AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL WE ARE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH
THEM AND AND BRING THEM.
SO MISTER KING EVERY I RECALL
THIS BEING A PILOT PROGRAM AND I
JUST WONDER MY NECK CONFIRMED IT
THAT IT IS A PILOT PROGRAM.
YEAH THAT'S THE WAY WE ARE
CONSTRUCTED EIGHT I AM REMEMBER
READING THAT BUT THERE'S A NOTE
HERE THAT SAYS IS THERE REALLY A
PILOT.
THAT THAT'S THE WAY THAT WE HAD.
IN INTENDED TO CONSTRUE
CONSTRUCTION THE BILL PERHAPS
ARE. IT EAST BE MAYBE THERE
NEEDS TO BE MORE GREATER
CLARITY.
SO WOULD PROBABLY IT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT'S AT I RECALL
IT BEING A PILOT. I CAN'T FIND
THE LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW BUT ALSO.
PROBABLY NEEDS AB.
A I SUNSET DATE SO THAT WE CAN
NOT. ENDED NUMBER TO COME BACK
AT THE EARTH THAT THOSE ARE NOT
AMENDMENTS OBVIOUSLY THAT WE'RE
ASKING YOU TO TAKE PART IN THIS
WHOLE BUT TO CONSIDER THOSE FOR
THE FUTURE. BE HAPPY TO THIS
ADDRESS THOSE OF THE NEXT
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I DO THINK
THAT.
THERE'S A REAL INTEREST IN IN
USING THIS KIND OF A PROGRAM IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA.
I I THINK IT'S ANYTIME YOU
GOING TO DO A PILOT IT'S GOOD TO
TRY IT OUT IN DIFFERENT AREAS TO
SEE HOW IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL OR
MAYBE HOW IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING
TO IMPLEMENT AND I I THINK IT'S
A GREAT ELEMENT OF SUPPORT
TODAY.
AND I LIKE TO SEE US DO MORE OF
THIS KIND OF WORK BECAUSE MORE
WE CAN PUT THESE REFRIGERATION.
.
DEVICES AT. IN IN OUR OUR STORES
IT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNIST
SELFRIDGE THINKS THAT COULD
COULD AGREE MORE I THINK IF YOU
COULD HELP US IDENTIFY PARTNERS.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN VERY GOOD.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SO THE ROLE PLEASE.
AB TWO THREE THREE FIVE THE
MOTIONS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
COMEY ROI COME BR I MATHIS.
MATHIS NO AGUILAR CURRY. A YEAR
CURRY AYE FLORA.
LARA NOT VOTING GALLAGHER GRAY.
GRAY AYE EGGMAN JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE SALAS. SALAS AYE.
NOW THE BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATING YOUR DOG AGAIN
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ANY MEMBER THERE.
COMMITTEES AND THEIR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO THAT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING FOR TODAY BUT WHAT I
WANNA DO IS TO.
CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS SO IF WE CAN GET THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE RIGHT NOW
SO THAT WE CAN FINISH OFF OUR
HEARING FOR TODAY. WE'RE NOT
DONE YET EXCUSE ME WE'RE NOT
DONE YET SO PLEASE LET US FINISH
UP.
WE'RE GONNA START AT THE TOP OF
THE LIST.
CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AGUILAR CURRY. A YEAR
CURRY AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE.
AB TWO ONE SIX SIX GALLAGHER.
EGGMAN.
AB TWO THREE THREE FIVE
GALLAGHER.
EGGMAN.
AB TWO THREE SEVEN SEVEN.
GALLAGHER. EGGMAN.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TEN AND YEAR
CURRY.
A YEAR CURRY AYE.
SALAS NOT LOADING TEN AYE
MILLER'S NOW.
AB THIRTY TWENTY ONE.
COMEY ARE OWNED BY. THE I A YEAR
CURRY.
A YEAR CURRY AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE.
SO WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE
OPENED FOR A COUPLE MEMBERS WHO
ARE NOT HERE RIGHT NOW IF WE
COULD CALL THEM AND MAKE SURE
THEY GET
EXCLUDES THE.
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE WERE
ADJOURNED